[Applause]
welcome to day three of vietnam
revisited a repeat of our program
originally seen over memorial day and
during the first hour of today we're
going to focus on ho chi minh
there in the background is the ho chi
minh mausoleum in the center of hanoi
and right around that area it's the ho
chi minh museum and the house in which
he spent a lot of his life
we'll take a tour of that and you can
see there workers
vietnamese workers out in front across
this mall area and right across behind
us there
where the camera is would be the
communist party headquarters
in hanoi for the country of vietnam
right through those doors there and
cameras are not allowed in them
where you can see two little white
specks those are two
army officers guarding that front door
there's no tourist at the time these
pictures were taken and you'll see later
in this hour where
young kids and their parents lined up on
holidays to pass through
the ho chi minh mausoleum where he is
lying at state
and katie kelly told us on monday that
there's no proof of this but they
recently took the body if it is the body
of ho chi minh to russia
and once again had the
the work that they do on bodies that lie
and stay like this like the london body
worked on and returned to the mausoleum
that's all hearsay and stories that she
picked up on her tour she was our guest
as many of you know on monday
her book a year in vietnam you're in
saigon was the subject of our first
day's discussion
later on today
fred downs will be back with us
fought in vietnam has written three
books reed irvine of accuracy and media
we'll
be here to talk about agent orange after
we hear once again the videotape that we
saw over memorial day a discussion with
elmo zumwalt and dr arnold schechter
about agent orange
and a gentleman by the name of tron von
kah
vietnamese who
now lives here in this country has done
very well in the restaurant business
but left that country his own country
years ago and came over here and started
working as a janitor at springfield mall
out here in
northern suburbs of virginia and today
now owns four restaurants and is doing
quite well and has set up a prosthetic
center to help the south vietnamese
in kanto where many of you probably were
stationed during the vietnam war i've
got to
show this to you earlier in the week a
little booklet it's written by
fan van dong
who many of you will remember was the
prime minister of vietnam
north vietnam back during the
negotiations in paris
and senator kerry told us yesterday that
the hearings in september slated to
start on september the 22nd for three
days september 21st for three days will
include the testimony of henry kissinger
who was involved in those paris
uh peace discussions and negotiations
back in the middle 70s this is a
book written by a longtime friend of ho
chi men's by the way
ho chi minh was born in 1890 and died in
1969
as the leader of the communist party and
is the leader of
the country of vietnam and
some feel
that he was one of the great
revolutionaries of this century
um i read you some of the
words in this booklet not as an
endorsement but just to reflect what his
longtime friend this was written
back in 1990
and
this was fan vandong's
view of ho chi minh
uh ho chi minh left by the way left the
country of vietnam in 1911 i believe it
was as he writes in this little booklet
you can buy this in the bookstore there
downtown near the metropol hotel
and uh stayed away from vietnam for
almost three decades
uh
lived in china lived in great britain
came to the united states for a while
also
lived in paris and it was in paris that
uh
mr pham points out here uh
where ho chi minh started the french
communist party in about 1920 1921
uh after of course the
founding of the bolshevik revolution in
1917. i don't tell you this is a
historian which i'm not i'm not an
expert on ho chi minh i'm sure many of
you in this audience can
dial us up later and tell us things that
you know about ho chi minh
certainly a lot more
in depth than i can but this particular
booklet
gives us some of the flavor
of what
the communist party leaders in vietnam
feel about ho chi minh today
it says it was rare for a genius born of
a colony deeply concerned with the
downtrodden
downtrodden life of an enslaved nation
and worried from his youth about the
destiny of his nation to have a chance
to investigate the situation of many
dependent and oppressed countries of the
world
to participate in the european workers
movement to combine quintessential
elements from the traditions of vietnam
and the east with modern achievements of
the western industrialized civilization
and to encounter marxism leninism
through his own encyclopedia knowledge
ho chi minh's revolutionary pilgrimage
was none other than a process of history
showing that after going through
torments man would meet scientific
socialism the revolutionary theory on
the liberation of man
mr pham recognizes and we understand
he's still alive still living in vietnam
and in his 80s
recognizes the changes that had to be
made in vietnam and where their actual
economic system has changed
a good distance away from what was
envisioned through communism and
we'll share some more of this as we go
through this hour
next up i want to show you the
ho chi minh museum
this was
open recently
and is probably the most expensive
building in the whole country
it's the newest building in the whole
country and this facility is right
behind
the ho chi minh mausoleum that you saw
earlier when we opened this program
so
foreign
it's a statue of hoe and a little child
and right in the front of the statue it
says in vietnamese bach ho which stands
for
uncle ho
something that most people in the
country it's the way they refer to ho
chi minh
that statue is right outside the rex
hotel
the rex hotel that used to be a bachelor
officers quarters
for the u.s military u.s army during the
vietnam war
and a hotel that many international
visitors now stay in when they go to
vietnam and as we
said earlier in the week they room
charges around 40 50 a night
in
saigon now this is a
a bookstore
where this little pamphlet i was reading
earlier
was purchased
and that's a statue of
ho chi minh right in the middle of the
bookstore bookstore is right in the
center of hanoi
about three stores down from the
metropol hotel
and in this one of the things i remember
seeing in this bookstore was a
display of the book scarlet
you might even there's a
couple of pamphlets over there
frankly in that whole story there
weren't that many
booklets about or books about ho chi
minh
the book that i have in front of me is
in english most of the books there of
course were in vietnamese
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
so
[Music]
saw some of the books there on the some
of them in english most of them are in
vietnamese what's on your screen right
now is a live picture of a ho chi minh
statue that i bought while i was there
for a dollar i'll show you how big it is
compare it to the size of the hand
it's hollow
and you can buy those all over the
country
no no sense of how many are purchased
but they're available
in in many of the knickknacks stores
and as the vietnamese will tell you they
compare ho chi minh with our george
washington
we're going to uh
look at the schedule in just a moment
for the rest of the day this will be
with you for another five minute four
five hours and 45 minutes this is a
five-part series it originally ran on
memorial day weekend
and we had so many requests to repeat it
that's why we're doing it this time
during an august period that is fairly
quiet here in washington and we can plan
ahead in this booklet that
fam von dong wrote the former prime
minister of
vietnam he's still an advisor to the
communist party
he says
while vietnam was fighting against u.s
aggression western writer and journalist
helene tormey
wrote quote
in ho chi minh everybody finds the
noblest most simple and dearest member
of his family
compared with
weapons
that does not yield to all the weapons
of the seventh fleet ho chi minh's image
is the perfect combination of buddha's
wisdom
jesus fraternity marxist philosophy
lenin's revolutionary genius and the
feeling of a master of a family all that
wrapped in a most natural manner again
reading what the vietnamese think of
their
dead leader
ho chi minh in this little booklet
and
for the moment let's look at the rest of
the day schedule
spend about 20 minutes around the ho chi
minh mausoleum
watching people visit
taking a look at what the area looks
like
in about four minutes
then an army museum tour
the army museum one of those spots that
your tour guide usually takes you to
there in
hanoi the senators who we followed also
visited this museum we went there on a
separate day so we could take a little
closer look
then at 110 we'll take up the subject of
agent orange once again and a visit to
the tudo hospital in
saigon a hospital that
has about 750 beds was built in three
different periods that we'll learn the
last period i think a couple years ago
built with the germans
and
at 2 30
after the segment on agent orange our
guest will be
reed irvine for about 30 minutes of
accuracy in the media
here to discuss
another view of agent orange a view
somewhat contrary to what elmer zumwalt
and dr arnold schechter have to say
during the program
then at 3 45 in saigon there is a
prosthetic research center
a place where
people who have
lost limbs either in the war or in
any uh other endeavor since the mid 70s
can go to this actually
some of the people we talked to lost
their limbs in the 60s
and this is funded by
partially by a gentleman out in seattle
and
following that a return visit with fred
downs at 4 30.
former uh
army officer who's written three books
about his experience and he himself has
lost he lost his left arm
in the vietnam war and he will be joined
by tran von
a vietnamese american who is himself
involved in trying to assist his
people over there in kento
and then on thursday we shift to the
subject of the economics of the
situation in vietnam and that part of
the world james clad of the carnegie
found carnegie endowment will be here
for an hour to discuss
places like indonesia and singapore and
korea and
malaysia and thailand and how they fit
into the vietnamese
part of the world
u.s vietnam relations former navy
secretary james webb it was the subject
of a parade magazine article that he
wrote
back on sunday august 23rd and then of
course as the day goes on on thursday
the phones will be open
no open phones on
friday it's all videotape
and
primarily following the
senators of the mia pow select committee
who made the trip in april that we
followed them both in hanoi and down in
saigon then on to the mekong delta
there's the army museum tour that they
took the hanoi prison trip that was spur
of the moment in hanoi right outside of
hanoi and then a couple of hours landing
in some five different areas down in
the mekong delta including
kanto and
fuqua island and other spots where
senator john kerry and senator smith
made a full day's trip
down to the delta
and that's the schedule for the rest of
this week
um up next
we have the uh
view of the ho chi minh mausoleum and
the ho chi minh
house of styx which is right behind it
let's roll tape and we'll be back with
you in about 20 minutes
they're shaking their head they're not
ready to roll tape
oh first stop yes thank you
uh we have the viewer response clip this
is uh for those of you who've been with
us this week know that um
back over memorial day
we listened to a lot of what you had to
say via telephone those that you
couldn't get through on the phones and
we taped a lot of that there were some
3000 calls and here is a brief segment
of what you had to say back then about
the vietnam revisited special
i would like to know what is being done
about the agent orange i've been i had
applied in 1988 and i have gotten
nothing so far all i get is
different things being done first is the
congress and
now i heard that the uh
mr durensky is holding it all up i
wanted to say let's expose the va
as
not assistance to veterans but assist
the government in depriving veterans
you can't resolve this and continue with
the healing process
until this is
exposed as a disabled vietnam veteran my
input is that uh being spit upon by the
hippies as we came home
was like a warm spring shower compared
to what the way
our government and the va
has treated us since we've been back
here
i'd like to have brian bring us up all
these people on
the va hospital in richmond virginia for
instance has
war after war that are vacant
and they're turning people away every
day don't know where the hell they're
going
they just wander around the streets and
they the place is a brand new hospital
and the places are vacant
i wonder what
the programming was very good and
thorough but i think everybody misses
the point
the reason why we have these pows and
mias declared dead is so that the
government
quits paying money money is the bottom
line and that's why we all suffer
i am a plw family member and i am sick
of being used as the reason to hurry up
and conclude investigations my anguishes
are governments not wanting to bring the
men home more than i loved them being
unaccounted for i will not fly the
american flag until live ones come home
i will fly the pow flag the pows stand
for the real meaning of the american
flag
here some vietnam veteran and still on
active duty in the marine corps
after 23 years
um
i find it difficult to continue to
listen to
all vietnam veterans blaming the
government for
inactions and uh and all the problems
that they might have i think people need
to get on with their lives and
recognize those of us who are veterans
and have been successful also
hearing from the public at large there
back uh over the uh memorial day weekend
this is the uh parade magazine piece
from august the 23rd those of you who
like to uh
get these kind of things and read them
for yourself and this was on august the
23rd we said it features jim webb who
used to be the secretary of navy and
tran van ka who will be our guest later
on today we're going to take a couple of
calls before we show you the ho chi minh
mausoleum first up from sumner
washington go ahead please hi hello hi
um i would like to know are there any
more
anti-communist
vietnamese and what do the people who
fought against the north feel
now and do they admire ho chi minh
and that's what i would like to know
that's an excellent question we asked
some of them while we were over there
and uh as you can imagine a lot of them
when asked about ho chi minh in that
country are not about to say anything
negative about him so uh i i we we don't
we don't really i have nothing on tape
to show you maybe we can ask mr uh tran
van carl when he comes
later and see what he says about it uh
pittsfield maine go ahead please
yes hi
my name is joe redman from pittsfield
maine and i have a question and i think
that a lot of viewers might want to know
this
uh i'm a veteran
and i wasn't located in kanto in 1969
and i i made some friends over there and
how would one
be able to contact or find the people
that uh
that you knew back then the vietnamese
that you made friends with
have you thought about going back
i have thought about it uh very much uh
but uh
this program has really kindled the uh
the situation
well you know we were in kento and you
can go there on your own uh there's you
can get a tourist visa you can get a
trip a tour trip
a package trip if you want there are all
kinds of ways to go back go ahead are
there any organizations
that can help search out
certain people
there are veterans organizations i don't
have the name of one right now but i
thank you for your call and by the time
this this afternoon is over we'll try to
get
a contact point for you and one of the
things you might do again
uh i do not have the answer directly is
you could contact your local veterans
groups and see if there's anyone in any
of the american legion of the veterans
of foreign wars
or the vietnam veterans that have groups
there are groups that have been formed
we ran into uh
a couple of veterans when we were over
there
and uh michael depalo was one who lives
up in onset massachusetts and spent a
lot of time with michael and he had gone
over there on his own but he also knew
of groups so we'll check and see if we
can't
get a better telephone number for you or
a better idea of where you can contact
but thanks for the call
as we said next up by the way that's
we're looking that's in in saigon
right outside of saigon and uh that's an
old huey helicopter i'm sure many of you
recognize it that was just sitting there
in the park
and when we saw it we stopped and
took some pictures of it
back to hanoi
take a look at the ho chi minh mausoleum
[Music]
mr hung what is the reason for all of
these folks standing in line to go into
the ho chi minh mausoleum
so people you know come here on holidays
especially a lot of people on sunday
they come here to pay homage to the
president which means the late with
personal to me
and sometimes they bring their flowers
and
you know
floral wreath
to put down in front of the
mausoleum to pay homage when you go into
the mausoleum what do you see
you can see the body imbalance body of
the president ho chi minh
and why do people feel that they need to
pay homage to him
because
ho chi minh is much revered by the whole
nation of vietnam
what's the reason he's reviewed
because you know
he
helped the nation to win
independence for the country
and do they get
lessons in ho chi minh in school early
yeah
they in a school they have lessons you
know on a moral
to study more on the example of the
president ho chi minh can you remember
how many years he was president of
vietnam
the president yeah how many years was ho
chi minh president
so uh you know since the
1945 and what year did he die
1969.
do you happen to remember that when they
built this mausoleum
uh it was after his death it was built
up the mausoleum
does everybody who lives in vietnam
feel that they should come and pay
yeah tribute yeah
especially for president ho chi minh
people
love him and
respect him
as the national hero what are the other
things that he's most remembered about
his leadership what was so good about
his leadership
so you know
people like him also as a post
personality
personally he loves children you know
and he
spent all his life
uh
for the country not for his own interest
what do you think he would think if he
were alive today about what's happened
since 1969
i don't know
you have no idea i have no ideas
is there anybody else in vietnam that
has the kind of status that he does
yeah you know
i think that he is unique
why
as for me it's my um personal
uh you know opinion i understand but why
do you think that uh
he is unique to this country what makes
him different than all this you know uh
a great exploit that he have done for he
has done for the country
and after you go into this mausoleum
what else do you do there are other
things you can see around this area yeah
you can see around this area you can go
visit the wooden house
where the president
was living
and you can see the
residential palace
near here
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
hello
what's on your screen right now is a
photograph
that's printed on what looks to be
almost plastic
i've got it in my hand
and
i bought this at the museum
for a dollar and it's the the frame that
you'll see here in just a moment is made
out of paper
uh you can see it right there that's all
you know it's fairly light
but
pictures like that of course like they
are here in this country available all
over they have back to this little
booklet that i was reading earlier
there's some insight those of you just
joined us for talking about ho chi minh
and we're going to show you the house of
sticks in just a moment uh where he
spent a lot of his life
fan
actually the right way to pronounce it
i'm sure is
who was the prime minister of vietnam
back in the days where ho chi minh was
the president and is still living and is
living in in hanoi
wrote about ho chi minh he said about ho
chi minh's daily life here i have
nothing new to say as his life was
interwoven with work
revolution
struggle
and
man
however
i recall something that is rarely
mentioned whether at home or abroad ho
chi minh never took holidays
every day he kept a strict timetable he
possibly rested when meeting pioneers
children and especially our southern
compatriots and fighters during the war
of resistance against u.s aggression
are when watching a film on saturday
nights in the presidential palace with
children of fellow workers sometimes he
received foreign guests or ambassadors
from fraternal countries during these
film shows
i would like very much to relate here
the details of his meals spartan meals
so many people could not imagine them
however what impressed me was that
during the meals he told us
to eat up dish and leave an untouched
one i recall this in order to
demonstrate his kind heart his respect
for those who prepared the meal and
furthermore for those who prepared the
ingredients of the meal this is a little
booklet here that you can buy when
you're in vietnam called ho chi minh a
man a nation an age and a cause
written
signed in 1990 by pham von dong
behind
the mausoleum is what they call the
wooden house house on sticks
and here's about eight minutes of what
that looked like on the day we were
there back in april
two months
two months you've been learning yes
and where in school
in university college
why why are you learning english
in vietnam in vietnam
for here evening
evening
i learned english from
half past seven and half pattern night
every night
do you like it
yes you lie you like english is it easy
hard is it hard for you to learn
is it is it difficult
19 ninety thousand dollars
[Music]
is a ho chi minh house of steam
what's this building right here
president's palace
you know who lives there now did someone
live in that house now now
it is
president ho chi minh
he knows
[Music]
again
[Music]
[Music]
yeah well every day in the morning in
the early morning president ho chi minh
uh was doing uh exercise
i mean uh
you know
morning exercise
where are along this road here
working
you know at least in about 200 meters
and i think
in the afternoon after hard working
president also walk down this
street for relaxation
[Music]
how long ago was this used
i may
you know from 1958 until 1969
uh we
have kept this intact
since the death of the president ho chi
minh and this is the bench for uh the
children because on holidays sunday for
example which means often gathered
children come here to cheer him up and
to talk with the children the children
would sit around sitting around
here i notice there are telephones over
on the corner yeah
what would the telephones used for the
obvious keep them in touch
this is the house where the president ho
chi minh
uh was living in the
in vietnak
in the you know revolutionary strong
revolutionary base and then this is uh
some example for building up this house
so this house yeah here is uh really a
replica of
this house a revolutionary nice base
now there are
11 chairs around that table there does
that mean there were 11 members of the
public bureau
today
uh
he was residing over the meeting sitting
in this return chair
wow
good
during the war
the president ho chi minh was not
evacuated from here
and so for his safety
we built up this bomb shelter for him
because he stayed here and worked was
working
and the bombs were dropped
three kilometers from here
on the ground
the president was feeding fish
in the fish pond
wow
foreign
foreign
[Music]
the house of stilts ho chi minh
who lived from 1890 to 1969
was the
chairman of the party the president of
the country and this little book that
we've been reading out of
tells us what uh the people of vietnam
thought or the party people thought of
him
dong who is the prime minister uh in
this little booklet
which was published in 1990 wrote that
ho chi minh was a living image of
revolutionary virtue he demonstrated
public spiritedness industry thrift
integrity righteousness
i'm sorry rightness
kindness intelligence and courage
with a new content which he said to the
entire party and the whole people
mr pham also wrote ho chi minh was a
strategist leader organizer and of the
same time a man of culture a journalist
and a talented poet there's more
let's take a call here
from
eatontown new jersey go ahead please how
you doing brian i'm fine sir how are you
my name is jim burge and i'm national
coordinator and founder of vietnam
veteran agent orange health study i'm
doing a privately funded out of my own
pocket health
study on vietnam veterans and their
families and i found a high rate of
cancers and a very very high rate of
birth defects among vietnam veterans and
their families due to their exposure to
agent orange
and i was wondering if somebody today
would be able to answer you know when
the veterans administration is credibly
going to do something for vietnam
veterans and their families there's
already legislation to do something for
persian gulf vets i like to know when
this country is going to start
recognizing the serious health problems
vietnam veterans and their families are
having and
do something credible about it
all right sir thanks for the call we
don't have anybody's schedule today to
answer that question directly we'll put
it in the mix and maybe before
fred downs will be here late in the
afternoon we can ask him what his
opinion is of what the veterans
administration uh is doing la connor
washington go ahead please
hello you're on the air hello hello hi
how how are you fine uh this is a
beautiful program i watched the first
day that we were at that program and i
wanted to come on the line then
but
now finally i'm on the line and i want
to tell you i just come back from
obvious just before you and i have here
two dog decks but i found it by the dmz
swan
now don't hold on let me you just came
back from vietnam
just before you
and i was there in uh i came back the
7th of april why were you there
i want to see it i wasn't interested in
it that was all did you have any
relatives or anybody that was no no i'm
not even and
i'm an alien resident but i'm many times
a better american than the americans are
and you found you say two dog tags right
what did you do with them i still have
them here i hope to find the right
person for them
the right family are
that is a sad thing to have them in your
hands yes i uh i think you're
probably i don't know who i would
contact if i were you except that the
uh the the defense department with uh as
many thousands of people maybe the
gentleman was here yesterday could help
mr patak
yeah that's what i saw but i couldn't
get on the line then he would you know
you would i didn't get a telephone
number maybe we can find the one that he
gave out yesterday maybe i've got
actually maybe i have it written down
here
but he he gave us his phone number and
you could call him directly at his
office
uh well that's not the number
i don't know where it is we'll look
here's the number uh the number is 703
703 284 284
1297 1297
call his office and tell him what you've
got alan patak is his name
and uh he will uh i'm sure help you
thanks for calling appreciate it uh
daytona beach florida
yes sir my name is ronald wilsey i'm a
disabled vietnam veteran and my question
is this is a good program but
you don't have anybody from the va
representing so us vets can talk to
because we are poorly treated in
vietnam i mean we've got a we've got a
gentleman this afternoon uh in about
about 4 30 east coast time will be here
from the va
okay i appreciate it because there's a
lot of questions that we need to ask
okay thanks a lot for calling
next call and we're just going to take a
couple more we go to wichita kansas go
ahead please hello hi you're on the air
i watch cnn
every day
and yesterday
i
i saw the name from arizona what's your
name
uh the man from arizona
yeah
the congressman
senator you're talking about senator
mccain yes yes
and i hear the man he talk about the way
these people live over there
it's terrible
but here i think he's in the moon
because
in america and every corner in america
you find people
live worse than that people over there
what are you talking about
well he was talking about his own
experience when he was in vietnam
as a pow
back uh in
in the 60s and uh in the 70s
portland oregon go ahead please
portland oregon you're on the air yeah
i've got some real questions uh i don't
have any answers by the way you better
give us statements instead of asking me
questions okay uh my statement is that
uh
last week i met a bunch a couple of
vietnamese i hadn't met for 23 years
actually vietnamese americans now
vietnamese vietnamese
one was an amerasian girl but
my i have a son that has disabilities i
was in vietnam from 66 to 69. i have a
son with definite disabilities and as
these people were looking at my son they
were telling me that the hospitals are
full of people like this or children
like this
in vietnam to this day
and
the vietnamese government doesn't allow
people to come in there with cameras
they don't they don't know even if
you're a real vietnamese you come to the
states for a few years and gone back to
vietnam they won't allow you
to see these uh these children
the only reason this one guy knew about
it was because he delivered rice
well
i'm not sure that this is the same thing
but in a couple minutes you'll see a
tour of a hospital that uh
will show the children i'm just hoping
that you could we're allowed to see the
hospitals that
that have these children yeah i'm not
sure
and we thanks for the call by the way
i'm not sure that what we saw is
means anything other than that they let
us see it
i'm sure there's a lot that we didn't
see and we don't purport
that this
week
is a
true behind the scenes
look at everything this is what we
saw and most of what we asked to do we
were allowed to do and uh really it's
all for you to make up your mind we're
trying to have as many different people
here as we can to answer the questions
and also keep the phones open so that
those of you who have had other
experiences can let us know where we
might have been off track next up
about an 18-minute tour of the army
museum in hanoi
mr hung what's the purpose of the museum
it's a army museum it was founded in
1959
for
the purpose is
showing the history of our
people's army
its
exploits during the war against french
against americans
what is behind us there
behind us it is uh
the soviet-made uh
airplane fighter airplane and oh there
is wreckage of b-52
which was shot down during during the
night
in 1972
it was a
campaign of americans to launch
extensive bombing hanoi at that time
how much bombing was done of hanoi
during the war
uh i have got no exact figure on it
where were you during that time
uh i was evacuated at that time to the
villages
were there many people that were left in
hanoi yeah a lot of people have to leave
for hanoi at the time i had to leave
hanoi yeah
i only the civil militia
the
army forces stay in hanoi during that
time
especially the people who live next to
the
start strategic you know objects
have to leave the country that leave the
hanoi at the time how old were you in
1972
uh in 1972 i was uh
um
i
do you remember that time at all yeah i
remember that time because at that time
you know i remember i
with my grandmother sitting
in
the underground shelter bomb shelter and
my grandmother was praying
at that time
did you lose any family in the war
yourself
uh
distant relatives
of mine
now you studied in the soviet union yeah
what years
i got educated in the soviet union
and i think that
it's very useful for me
because i
to get trained as a
expert on
international relations and also i got
languagistic skills in the soviet union
did they teach you much about the
vietnam war that's what we call it the
vietnam war
and the soviet involvement
no
we study international relations
i i was i studied in the faculty of
international relations we studied the
history of international relations
we study a political economy
because i i was specializing in china so
i studied chinese and
chinese politicians chinese economy and
so on where did you learn to speak
english
in the soviet union too
now why would they teach you english
when you were studying about china
because
once you
if you are a diplomat for example you
have to learn
english english is world
language everybody has to know
how many vietnamese or hanoi citizens
come by a museum like this in a year do
you have is this a very popular museum
yeah it's very popular museum and
i think that on holidays
the school girls and boys come here
especially people from other provinces
other cities also come here to see
the
exhibition what do you think most
vietnamese people will think of when
they see
a mig-21 up there a russian airplane on
top of an american b-52 what comes what
do you think about when you see this uh
according to my own opinion i think that
we have to let by guns by
big backgrounds so we have to have to
look forward to look to the future
not to the past but we still not forget
about
the past
from your perspective what was the
lesson of the war between vietnam and
the united states
i think that every wars is
insane
so i think that we try to avoid every
war because everywhere
the war caused
a lot of damages to our nation
and now our
task i think that is to develop economic
economy
what are you taught much about the war
the world they're talking about the
american involvement in school here now
in high school
i still did the soviet tune in so uh
yeah at all in high school and all here
so after school i go to i went to the
soviet union
what else do you see in this museum
besides this b-52 wreckage
uh you can see uh
tanks
helicopters maybe
american weapons also
on exhibition on display at display
in this museum and how about other wars
besides the american war
about
the weapons we used during the war
against french also you can have a look
at
and over there there there are also the
uh
american pilot's belongings
what are you also taught about the
french war what was that 1954
yeah it was the great victory of
vietnamese people over french
and it it was also fierce battle indian
being full do you consider
the american war to be a victory yeah of
course
why were you victorious
because we win
we have won our independence and we
unify the country
and what do you think it is about the
vietnamese people that created
a vic a victory
so vietnamese people are very
you know
they have
fulfilled every
task
in order to to win the independence
whatever country what do the vietnamese
people think of americans today
so i think that
there is no problems between vietnamese
and american peoples
they think they think that
there is a friendship i must say that
between vietnamese
and american people
but you know
that's it
oh and i don't understand
i keep asking them if they don't like
the russians the russians help them win
the war i don't understand why they
don't like them because i like that the
russians
were here and if uh russians are so uh
you know so uh familiar to you so too
much familiarity with contempt that
too much primarily well there's still i
mean i still don't understand if it
wasn't for the right for me i i i i i
like the russians because everyone hates
russian they scream lately i don't know
but
in my opinion i like the russians
because russians
no
didn't cause any damage to our country
right
yeah because
i don't know is it just an answer where
are you from i'm canadian why are you
over here i was just on holiday in
thailand and um i don't know vietnam
seemed to be quite interesting
where in canada are you from i'm from
toronto what have you learned
um
um
i don't know it's kind of really hard to
put into words because i grew up in
united states so i was thinking back i
was like 10 years old when this was all
happening i was living in texas and i
don't know it was just kind of really
strange trying to think well what was i
doing during
you know
some parts are really sad like you go to
may lie and i was thinking i was 10
years old during the melee massacre and
that was really horrible he got really
depressed
but um did you go there have you been
there on this trip yeah yeah i just came
back from there um i don't know you
learned that war is horrible i mean no
one really was good or bad i do
i do
sympathize with vietnam they wanted
their independence i think i mean i
blame the french little knowledge of i
know i think the french should have
chatted with ho chi minh i think they
should have worked something out in 1954
and i do agree with their independence
everyone wants independence and they
don't like being a colony and i mean the
french really didn't they did colonize
them so
in that terms i think i sympathize with
them wanting their independence i don't
know i feel really sorry this is so
war-torn you walk around everyone you
look at everybody and you think
everybody i'm looking at has been has
been
somewhere during the war you're either
this little or i mean anyone my age i
think they were like 10 years old and
they they we had this really nice guide
and he was like 50. and i thought his
whole life he has seen war i mean he was
here doing the french and then with
americans everything i don't know you're
saying that you people think you're
russian yes everyone thinks we're
russian and i'm i mean i'm not trying to
be
say anything critical really i find it
very amazing how
they don't like the russians they really
don't people are really nasty i mean in
the south they were and in the north
they are and i don't understand it and
i've asked several people i don't
understand there i mean they helped them
win the war if it wasn't for the
russians that vietnam probably wouldn't
have won the war they aren't they gave
them all the arms necessary to do it and
now i don't know some people say because
the russians treated them badly and came
in or people are disappointed with
communism or i mean i really i don't
know and it's it's i mean he's gotten to
a point where insulted and people they
won't serve us they you can hear them
calling us lane zone they say no no
liens are here and we keep going come
fight linger we have to like show our
like canadian flags i mean
it's
what's left the biggest impression on
you besides that in uh vietnam
what left the biggest impression on me
um i mean if when you go back home and
you see your friends what do you what's
the person you're gonna tell them
there are resilient people i mean to
have come out of so many years of war um
they're actually
they've come out of it i mean they're
they're living their lives and they've
been able to come above that
i found the south i mean truthfully the
south was far more friendlier and i
think they liked foreigners a lot more
um i don't like think the north i don't
know why the north have been extremely i
mean some most people have not been as
friendly as the south and the south like
the foreigners much more
um
so um
i don't know
i don't know i
don't want to get kicked out of the
country but i mean at some at some
points
uh i don't know have you been able to go
wherever you wanted to go and see
whatever you want to see
uh yep we've been able to go wherever we
want to go and see whatever we see we um
but we were very lucky because we've
many of the travelers we met were not
allowed to go places so we were lucky we
were i mean someone gave us a really
good permit and we were able to go we
met people that came in and from hanoi
we started in saigon came in in the
airport in hanoi and they weren't able
allowed to go anywhere and we've driven
all the way up from
all the way up so i think it's a matter
of who you see i don't know how much you
pay
thank you very much
hey
[Music]
[Music]
what's printed on here
the americans
were running off saigon
what about they tried to get in the
the helicopter
to flee saigon at that time in 1950
1975. now what about the pictures below
of the
military leaders
so
according to the inscription
the notation
saying that
the generals
who suffered defeated in vietnam
and the
presidents
who
suffered defeat in vietnam
president eisenhower kennedy johnson
nixon ford
loyal to the peoples and
ready to
sacrifice
for independence freedom
of the country of the fatherland
for the socialism
we will fulfill
whatever
a task assigned for us
and we'll
we win
one
we we will win whatever enemy
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so
i am american american
i could not speak vietnamese
now i have got mishap
and
i i want to get your help
your food
your house housing
and
i i want you to protect me
[Music]
i want you to bring
here
someone who could protect me and take me
back to to my country
my
my government
our government
thank you thank you a lot
for this
[Music]
so
what uh what are we looking at here
uh this is one of the tanks
which broke the gate
of the presidential palace in ho chi
minh city
in the earth 30th of april 1975.
is that a big date in this in the
american vietnam war uh it's very big
date it's we every year we celebrate
this date why because
it is uh
the date of liberation of ho chi minh
city and their day you must say that the
day of reunification of our country
how do you celebrate today what do you
do on that day so uh people
took one day and a half off
and stay home or just to go to see to
visit friends to go to the parks to do
for for the sake of relaxation
what has the reunification of the
country meant how has the country
changed since 1975
i think that
at present moment
we have seen a lot of changes since
1975.
now the
uh
the state
you know or
our country is moving towards market
economy and since the state promoted
this policy i i have seen a lot of
changes good changes for the better by
the way mr hung who's
who built this tank
uh i don't know
does it matter
it doesn't matter
i think that this is a soviet one
mr hung by the way
spent about eight years in uh russia
where he was educated he's a vietnamese
he was assigned to us by the
foreign ministry on our trip there and
spent the entire time that we were in
hanoi with us
and you've seen a lot of him on camera
if you've just joined us this is vietnam
revisited some 30 hours of programming a
repeat from what
was with some changes by the way from
what you saw over memorial day weekend
at your request we've
brought all this back so that you can
have another look at it for those of you
who've never seen it before let's take a
brief look before we grab this first
call at the part of the world we're
talking about over here on this map just
so you can
catch up on on what this is there's
hanoi
and
the country of vietnam now together it
goes all the way down here to where
saigon is
right next to it is cambodia
up here is thailand
right over here is laos
and
this country has about 70 million people
in it laos somewhere on the order of 4
million
cambodia about 7 million in thailand
about 60 million people just to give you
some sense of what that part of the
world looks like takes you about
30 hours to get there from here via
airplane we have a call waiting we're
going to take a couple calls before we
continue the programming from tupper
lake new york go ahead please yes brian
um i've been watching for the last three
days i'm a vietnam veteran
and uh former marine i spent two years
fighting with the ninth marines in
northern i-corps
caisson siege
forward uh when you say i-corps for
those who have never heard of i-corps
what does that mean that's up the area
right around the dmz and it works about
20 miles south see if i can get it up
here it's
right in this
general area
that's correct
you might see caisson on the map if it's
still there dungha quang tree
yeah okay
i was a forward observer and i was in 26
operations i was wounded i'm a disabled
veteran now
and i i just want to say that i i
appreciate everything that you're doing
but your guests the people that you
constantly seem to have on
viewing you know or uh talking about
their uh perspectives and so forth on
vietnam senator mccain
senator smith senator kerry
these people are not representative of
the
of the combat veteran who fought day to
day in the bushes through all those
periods and i think this is well known i
i wish
that you would make a concerted effort
to get what were called grunts
these are people that pounded the bush
on these various operations day in and
day out who came back to an ungrateful
country who have never
forgotten vietnam
they live with it every day
all right uh
i accepted your segment let me first of
all you should know that's why these
phones are open and i want to ask you a
couple questions about your own
experience
are you what kind of disability do you
have
malaria wound post-stress syndrome
can you work
uh
it's very difficult to gain employment
once you see you're compelled to tell an
employer what's wrong with you what kind
of service disability you have
they've never understood that what that
what it is what it means and you know
frankly in today's market uh uh
uh it's a risk it's a long shot how old
are you i'm uh 48 years old what kind of
help does the government give you what
kind of money do they pay you a month
well i'm rated at fifty percent
disability and uh and social security
pays it as well how what what is it what
do you take home do you get uh twelve
thirteen hundred dollars a month no less
less
what about medical care can you get your
your uh problems taken care of yeah i'm
a hundred and uh i'm 200 we treat
ourselves uh most veterans of the
vietnam war have never gone near the va
how come you people don't know that
well that's why we're listening here
years we treat ourselves
if it's a tooth if it's a cut if it's an
abscess if it's pain in our sides
you know i
in the beginning they rolled their eyes
when they saw us coming they didn't want
to deal with the numbers that came back
from southeast asia don't you understand
that we don't trust the veterans
administration we don't trust the
federal government to take care of us is
it because of the way they treat you
when you show up at the hospital
well there's a human factor
at play anywhere you go uh we distrust
because of uh and and and you know
when our profile was raised again under
the uh under president reagan
when uh you know he made the country
understand that there might be an
obligation they had to us we felt better
about going back in but you've got to
remember that there have been thousands
and thousands of men who have taken
their own lives because of what went on
uh in the early 70s and and the late 60s
it was it was much too late
most men like myself were overridden
with guilt
did that were even still here
how much do you think about it
uh vietnam every day of my life you you
you just can't you you you don't
understand and and you know uh i i i i i
in the beginning it had nothing to do
with disability claims it had nothing to
do with anything that
uh monetary uh it had to do with respect
uh to appreciate that we were warriors
that we will that what we had done what
our country asked us to do and then when
we came back and went through what has
been a war for us just to uh to
to peacefully coexist in a civilian
population
you you have to understand the extent of
that and and and understand that we were
patriots and that what we we believed
the words of john kennedy and we went uh
we went forward
and uh
you we the biggest mistake that most of
us made brian was coming back
was getting out of there alive
all right that's as true today as it was
uh 25 years ago thanks for sharing your
thoughts with us hinesville georgia go
ahead please uh thank you
uh it looks like you're not on yet
no we're on oh okay
first of all i'd like to thank you for a
wonderful program i'm also a vietnam
veteran
uh
i'd like to to mention about some of the
things that you that you on the show had
questions about
i've i'm married to a vietnamese
uh lady my whole family is i've helped
over a hundred people come here under
the orderly departure program uh i'm
familiar with the conditions in vietnam
today tell me as well as before tell me
first quickly uh when did you fight
there
uh 1968 69 and 70. what service
i was army a grunt and when did you
marry a vietnamese woman
oh let's see that was 1980. and at that
time i was working at the uh war college
in carlisle pennsylvania where did you
meet her in carlisle i see and you have
uh children uh yes i do and you have a
lot of relatives that are vietnamese uh
quite a few and of course you know all
the friends come for translation help
and all the papers that are required by
the government and all this how is it
going in your opinion the transfer of
people from vietnam to the united states
well first of all i want you to
understand that everyone that has left
there has paid a ransom to the north
vietnamese government or vietnamese
government as it is now paid money they
pay hard cold cash how much
it varies uh this is part of you you
mentioned about the interview this is
the big
uh deal this is the time when the
government
gets the family or family members that
want to leave they assess their value
and their support back in the states
then they levy them so it's averaged
three thousand dollars a piece what's
the most you've ever heard of
uh seven to ten thousand dollars because
they suspected that the the people
operated a business there and sent money
that was waiting for him in the states
where do they get the money to pay the
north vietnamese government well from
the relatives you have to be sponsored
by by blood relatives back here does
everybody that leave there have to pay
this kind of ransom absolutely everyone
now
if you if you ask to confirm this with a
family who still has family members
there they'll deny it
now there's three or four
on the east coast uh places where you
pay this money and three or four on the
west coast
and their business is set up to transfer
the funds electronically
back to vietnam to pay the vietnamese
government now as soon as these funds
are paid
then
they're uh they're told that they'll be
permitted to leave the country and
exactly at that time
one of the the vietnamese government
officials accompanies the family member
back to their home and makes an
inventory
you have a refrigerator you have a
radio you have two chairs five rice
bowls this all then becomes property of
the government
uh i can answer all kinds of questions
uh the lady that wrote a book wondered
why she wasn't permitted to to teach
that's another
money source the government of vietnam
is looking for hard currency u.s dollars
teaching english brings in those us
dollars
she was doing as a volunteer they don't
want that
everything every dealing that we have
with them is corrupt and it's aimed at
having hard currency dollars
the politicians that you've had on there
that say we ought to normalize relations
they're they're talking with the oil
companies and everybody else that think
they're going to go in there and and
make fast bucks
we should not support that time in this
country right now all right thanks a lot
hinesville georgia moraga california go
ahead please yeah good morning hi uh
listen i was just curious if on your
travels um if you've had the opportunity
to visit cameron bay
and one of the reasons i'm curious about
it is um
there's been some speculation in some
readings and materials i've come across
in the past year or so
that speculate that one of the reasons
the american military was so the
american navy if you will
was so willing to let its presence in
the philippines go was there looking
downstream
as it were toward camp toward occupying
cameron bay i know that during the 60s
the military well actually the taxpayers
poured hundreds of millions of dollars
into developing that area and it's one
of the few well-developed deep water
ports in the area have you are you a
veteran oh no my brother is i'm not i
was trying to i you know i asked when i
was there to go to cameron bay and i'm
trying to find it on on the uh
i think it's right there yep and get a
it's right below in the trunk yeah my
brother's in the navy he was there he
was there for a few years in the 60s
yeah i asked to go out there and to see
that and we were told no and usually the
reason they give you is we didn't ask
far enough in advance and and although
he gave me the impression that because
of the military nature of that area we
couldn't go there i i think we could
have gone into trying but we couldn't go
down to cameron bay but thank you by the
way for a question it's an interesting
question and maybe somebody before the
days over can answer it for us a lot of
things as you know here are not going to
be
a lot of problems are not going to be
solved certainly and a lot of questions
are not going to be answered because in
many cases there aren't any answers or
the people that come here
don't have the answers or some of the
people that do won't come talk to us and
i'm talking uh also about people from
vietnam who um
they were we had a gentleman here with
us last time we don't have anybody here
this time anyway um we've got a lot more
to show you today we'll be
let's see i'm trying to calculate the
number of hours we've got another four
hours and 40 minutes from today up next
is a visit to toudou hospital it's an
obstetric hospital there in saigon katie
kelly talked about it in her book she
was there for the birth of a child one
night where she said she
fainted and fell to the to the
floor there in the delivery room
we're talking about a book katie kelly
wrote called a year in saigon
she taught english left her job at nbc
up in new york where she was a
television critic and
movie critic
anyway you're going to also hear up next
before we go to that tour of the
hospital and
i warn you that some of the scenes in
the hospital are not particularly um
they're difficult to watch warning in
advance when you uh look at it because
you're going to see some little children
who are
some of them don't have their limbs
and their and we'll discuss this before
we go there so you'll you'll know what
to expect uh also after that week after
the tour you come back and and we're
elmo zumwalt former chief of naval
operations and dr uh gerald schechter
who is at the
state university of new york an expert
on agent orange we'll talk about the
whole issue of agent orange and then
following this segment which runs about
oh it's an hour and
some minutes 10 minutes or so we'll be
back with reader violent accuracy and
media who has some
other views on agent orange and the war
and we'll discuss that for about a half
an hour and also take your calls during
that so let's let's go to this was
recorded back in may before our vietnam
revisited special ran over memorial day
and it's uh admiral zumwalt and dr
schechter and then the tour of tudu
hospital in saigon
dr arnold schechter one of the things we
did on our trip to vietnam was visit a
hospital in ho chi minh city that that
i was going to say deals with the agent
orange problem you know better
than i do what we were visiting tell us
what was that hospital all about
you and also i were visiting the
obstetrical and gynecological hospital
in saigon city in the ho chi minh city
province
and that hospital takes
referral difficult cases as the mayo
clinic would in this country or mass
general
so we saw
and you saw and we've been working since
1984
with some of the cases of malformations
which they believe
sometimes are related to agent orange
some of the cancers which may or may not
be related to agent orange some of the
mental retardation and the inability to
fight infections
that's the largest obstetrical hospital
in the south of vietnam
okay we're gonna we're gonna show the
audience a long 45-minute sequence in
just a moment also our guest in this
segment is admiral elmo zumwalt retired
agent orange
big impact on your life uh tell us just
a little bit about that and also whether
or not you think it's still an important
question to be dealt with well briefly
when i took command of the naval forces
vietnam and had to move our small craft
into the narrow rivers and canals along
the cambodian border
in the dense foliage we began to take
casualties at the rate of six percent a
month which meant the average young man
had about a seventy percent probability
of being killed or wounded during his
year
of service
i then used asian orange as the army had
been for three years
to defoliate the banks a thousand yards
on each side and reduce the casualties
to less than a percent a month
so we saved thousands of lives but we
now know that the cost of that
has been
hundreds of lives lost due to cancer and
many other lives affected by birth
defects of the progeny of some of those
veterans you lost a son
i had a son who was in command of one of
those small craft
who
15 years later came down with two
different forms of cancer both
non-hodgkin's lymphoma and hodgkin's
and after a five-year battle
and a transplant we lost him what year
in 1988 and do you attribute that to
agent orange yes i think in my son's
case the fact that he had two different
forms of cancer
makes it
very probable
obviously people are gonna die of cancer
whether or not they went to vietnam
and so what one always is talking about
is the effect at the margin i don't
think there is any doubt but what there
are greater numbers of cancers among
vietnam veterans and other effects than
among
control groups
should tell our audience also that and
we've mentioned this throughout this
series that a lot of what we were able
to do was on the run i mean we only had
a short time and people would say all
right the hospital is ready to see you
and we take off their cameras rolling
very spontaneous and we felt frankly
inadequate as we're going through the
process and not being sure of getting
the right answers and that's
we
we you and i met in vietnam and you were
gracious enough to come down here and
talk about this dr schechter how did you
get into the asian orange issue in the
first place and where are you doing your
work now
well i
am a veteran of the vietnam war i served
in the army medical corps but ironically
during that time we did not
know about agent orange or dioxin and we
were never told
i became involved in the diets in
question when we had a pcb transformer
fire in binghamton new york where i'm on
the faculty of the medical school there
and
the question came up did the dioxins get
into any of the workers the firefighters
or others cleanup workers or not
we realized that dioxins were being
measured in other countries but not yet
in americans
so we did in fact measure the dioxins
and the related chemicals
in americans and it was suggested if
you're interested in dioxins as a health
issue why don't you go to vietnam where
the largest dioxin contamination in the
world occurred
with ancient orange so i started
visiting the ministry of health in the
various hospitals in 1984.
what we wanted to know
was is there any
intake of dioxin into the vietnamese and
also of course we were concerned about
american veterans so we've now been
doing studies
in vietnamese to see if the dioxin
characteristic of agent orange is
elevated in some of the vietnamese
exposed to asian orange the answer is
yes in some cases there is an elevation
there is an intake
and
in american vietnam veterans in
massachusetts and michigan where we did
studies we found a smaller number
still have elevation of the dioxin of
agent orange so the question is where
did the dioxins move in the environment
after the herbicide spraying or other
exposures and how much does it take to
cause the health effects
the latter is the question we're about
ready to start looking at in vietnam i'm
going to come back and ask you to
introduce this tape which by the way
both of our guests have already seen
once and they will watch it with you for
the second time then we'll come back and
talk about it some more
you were
chief of naval operations what year
from 1978 to 1974 and you were in
vietnam what years from 1968 to 1970.
have you spent much time in the last 10
15 years on the agent orange question
and if so what yes
we began to study at my son and i when
we began to suspect that his cancers
were the result of exposure and then
when
secretary edward yowinski took office as
secretary of veterans affairs
he asked me to take on a special
assignment
at
no
no compensation to do a study of the
agent orange issue and i spent seven
months analyzing all of the studies and
talking to a great number of medical
experts including dr schechter and i
came up with a study which concluded
that
it was as at least as likely as not
which is what the law requires that
there
are
about 28 different health effects that
are
related to exposure to agent orange
as a way of introduction to this
this uh
tape uh
you see this stuff all the time we have
not and we should tell the viewers that
some of it might be quite
disturbing i would was that the way to
how would you
would you lead into this videotape and
tell the viewers how to watch it which
what what questions should they ask and
what should they be aware of
as we as we watch this 45 minute tape
this tape will give the viewers
the opportunity to see
a large obstetrical hospital in saigon
city
now known as ho chi minh city
the
most shocking the most disturbing part
for most viewers is
the room
with bottles of malformed
fetuses
or newborns
those are stored
in the anatomical museum of the
obstetrics hospital to illustrate male
formations which are occurring in the
south of vietnam
some vietnamese physicians believe that
a certain percent of the malformations
are
caused by
the dioxin in agent orange
that could be a biologically plausible
thing to believe we've seen that in
animals we've seen this in humans in
other episodes around the world
in addition they talk about
choreocarcinoma and hydatidiform mole
those are growths that are seen in
pregnant women
and following pregnancy including a type
of cancer
which may or may not be related to
dioxin
but
that there may be an excess of cancers
of certain types from dioxins
now is unfairly strong scientific ground
my
scientific guess would be that those
particular cancers are not
going to be found related to
dioxin based on the measurements we've
done in some of the women in that very
hospital
we did not find high elevated levels of
dioxins from that type of cancer we did
from other cancers but not that type
and that type of cancer is common in
southeast asia
so your viewers are seeing the largest
obstetrics hospital in the south of
vietnam
they're seeing certain types of cancers
or growths in the women who were
pregnant they're seeing malformations
they're seeing siamese twins
and they're seeing children who are born
with malformations as well as children
who died
from the male formations and who are
preserved in an anatomical museum again
before this is over you'll see addresses
for both of our guests on the screen
where you can contact them and the other
thing is as you watch this remember that
this was not
heavily produced on our part you will
see it moving very fast you're going to
have to listen closely because the
vietnamese tried very hard to speak
english but sometimes it's a bit broken
and we can't fault them for that our
vietnamese is not
non-existent so uh let's roll the tape
and we'll come back and get our guests
to comment on uh what you're about to
see
thank you
brian lamb hello how are you nice to
meet you
uh this is dr vice versa
dr chung nice to meet you
good doctor nguyen dr nguyen
[Music]
these folks aren't going to be able to
sit down because they have to run those
cameras yeah
i stick friends fairly expect
can you tell us what this hospital is
all about what is done here
please wait a moment how can you take
the history and the
statistics of the hospital
okay
now that's in the doctor's phone
she's committed to attend a meeting
from the national assembly
so that's why she cannot receive
you here today
but in honor
[Music]
doctors
will receive you the vice directors and
other doctors will receive you and take
you around the hospital great
and this is dr chung
[Music]
thank you
this is
[Applause]
says here you delivered twenty one
thousand seven hundred and fifty six
babies during yes yes
is that the is very much
it is is that is that it
your number one reason
for being here is a um
and
is 21 000
is that figure up or below what it has
been
what's the survival rate these days are
you
and what's the life expectancy of people
in vietnam
we have the
statistics about the
birth deliveries and the rates of the
survivors
but regarding the life expectancy that i
can
i don't know
because he
belonged to another
office
we were told that
this is the hospital that
dealt with agent orange and blue and
white
yes
how much
of
this do you deal with how much
effects from
[Music]
20 years ago do you have on people today
we have all these
um
these symptoms are supposed to be caused
by the asian orange and other
mainly by asian orange and other toxic
chemicals for the
congenital
death
and these are the consequences of the
effects upon the child the children and
the mothers
what what does happen to someone if
they've been affected by these ages
what's the physical and internal
uh
impact on a newborn
on
the effects of the toxic chemicals on
human beings
has the united states done anything
since the war to help
deal with this problem
[Applause]
to
make some laboratory experiments on the
uh some samples of soil
earth from sand to america from vietnam
and some of the fat tissue
the
tissues of them
taken from
the affected
woman
to america and america also send us some
research documents relating on the
effect of the chemicals
doctor how long have you been here at
this hospital
i think i haven't been working here
since 1975.
where were you before that
uh
where
were you did you fight or were you
involved in the war at all
[Music]
[Applause]
where did you go to medical school
what
are you still in the military now
sorry is he still in the military is
this is this a military run hospital no
no no no
uh
fighting involved in the struggle
how
much damage other than statistics in
your opinion have these agents done and
how long will it be before you can work
them out of the system
[Applause]
[Applause]
we
make research by the
comparisons
method
and then we
make the comparison
the cases you know of the deformities or
all this
before
the contamination that's meant before
the
the spread of chemicals by mannequin and
after the spray
well okay
after the liberation up to now with some
less research and we notice nationally
the cases
of
the symptoms and the cases of the
the sixth person or the deformities
and some defects not in the children on
the children increased
on the contaminated areas
and
as compared to with the uncontaminated
areas are as competitive with the
pre-spray the period
um
[Applause]
is very high in vietnam as compared to
with other countries in the world it
means other countries in the world also
there are
hundreds of months and for your casinos
cases but it's the rate here very high
in dinner
would you
show us around would it be possible to
see the hospital
patients who are supposed to be affected
by
this is the
our research on the
effect of the clinicals and we have
and this the document was delivered
after some
international conference on the
effects of the toxic chemicals
yes
[Applause]
how many doctors are there here at the
hospital
how many how many doctors
over 100
i don't know exactly
about
120
doctors and where where did you go to
medical school
uh yes yes where
where
i myself yes
hanoi you were from university yeah from
hanoi i come here in
1977 i was in hanoi
i worked in the
fixed position the mother and the
newborn baby where were you during the
war time
in war time i was in in the north of
vietnam
were you fighting in the north or are
you a doctor working with the uh
casualties
in the north or were you in a hospital
in hanoi
uh here no up there during the war
itself
were you were you in the military
were you in were you in the army
during the war
well
at the time in the war
i worked in the underground
what part of what part up in the north
of vietnam
not not in the south of britain
how do you think vietnam is doing after
20 years after the war
in general i mean is it are things
getting better
slowly please
you speak lonely okay let me try it
again
it's been roughly
17 years since the war ended in 1975
are things getting better for
the people of vietnam yeah
and if if they are getting better how
how are how is the in your opinion the
medical
treatment for people that live in
vietnam
yes
as you see after the war
so much difficulties
happen in our country
and so for the
human diseases
and if children diseases we can make the
prevention
of the
so much disease
for example
the newborn baby
we can't reduce the weight of the low
mobility and premature maybe
because
the weight of the premature and low bulk
weight in our country is until high
here you see
the department of
congenital landfill missions
we have a three
building
so this whole area is for
1965
american style
for the ogn association
us to
build this building for the congenital
reformation who are those little
characters
yeah
the most of them
are
congenital deformations
how old are they
four five
four five months
twelve months
how long sometimes
look here it's
eleven years old
with dark side mystery you're now him
no no
yeah
11 years old
that operated in the 1900
so what is wrong with those children
what's what's the what problems do they
have
because genital information
is wealthy but
made for missions
information yeah
now can that child
parents
are very
difficult and
poor
and so
the baby stay here
how old is that baby you know
three months three months
and d do you say that this this
malformation is caused by the agent
orange
and you see so much causes influence
from dioxin
but
one after calls
one of the codes
one of the causes one of the cause is
dioxin
perhaps the mother infection
or the
under nutrition
from the mother
and influence
so
congenital malformations
but
one after cause this
isn't live scene as you see now we
the in the
scientists in the world
who can analyze in fact
and in the blood
the level of dioxin
and in the in the start of vietnam
some of the patients
we send the specimen to
the
to american to united states and holland
and to analyze
the fat tissue
to detect in in the fetish or
taxi level is much higher compared in
vietnam and north of vietnam or south
is it north or south where the dioxin
content is higher
yeah in vietnam
this little baby here doesn't have
legs
what causes that you know
malformation
maybe it's caused by diocesan
maybe but we don't know for sure
[Music]
do these are their parents we make one
research we compare two
two groups one group
on the spray area
and one group in non-spray area and we
found out that the rate of main fog
missions in the spray area group
is much higher compiled in the non-spray
area
which way do you want to go doctor
who is who pays for those children to be
here
here yes
hospital
direction of the hospital
and sometimes in the
from the ogn
organization non-government
gave
us the finance and to
nourish is this an older child
11 years old 11 years old are they two
children
he had operated
six four in this hospital
where is the other twin brother goes to
school now goes to school very clever
and very intelligent
and he
had the unconscious
because uncivil like this
is performance in in japan for treatment
in japan
is he aware that we're here
he wasn't injured
he was born in
province
i'm sorry is this young fellow aware
that we are here now can he see us and
does he understand
no no no
a little but he
unconsciously
[Music]
where were the twins joined at what
point in their body where they joined
together
uh yes because the time is doing only
one another
one is fantastic one genital system
two legs two legs only
stitch one leg when were they separated
at what what age yeah what what age were
they separated
at nine eight
eight
eight
very difficult
yes
[Music]
how old is he
are there parents did their parents
bring them here or do you know
is this hard for
nurses like this to work with all the
time work with children that are uh yes
always here is it difficult though
[Music]
because
he has
the
maxi levels yeah
no
no legs
how about the other babies is there
anything wrong with them
abandoned
baby
the mother
go away
abandoned
baby but the baby's normal
how long will this baby stay here
one
one year or one and a half year and
after we give to the
parents adopt for adoptive for adoption
is it hard to find parents in vietnam to
adopt children
vietnam or the other country french
germany americans ever adopt any of
these children
now this child here is deformed isn't he
yeah it's a heart disease
short short arms
[Applause]
what's the little fella over here's name
the one without the legs
oh
happiness
but
he's unhappy
how long will he be here
and then what will he be up for adoption
yeah
no no no
no no no no no
but what will happen i mean if he if
what will happen to a child like this
for the rest of his life
where will he be
but i think now the
arms can prepare the arms
for him
the two legs
for activation legs
but
this maxillaris is very difficult
this time they can eat can eat easily
[Applause]
every day he can eat candy
yeah 15 15 kg
as enough for us
very very difficult to nourish
them every day every day and night
thank you very much thank you
for adoption yeah
no no no
no no no no
but what will happen i mean if
what will happen to a child like this
for the rest of his life
where will he be
but i think now the
arms can prepare the arms
for him
the two legs
for activation legs
but
this maxillaris is very difficult
this time
you can eat
can eat easily
every day he can eat candy
enough for us very very difficult to
nourish
them every day every day day and night
thank you very much thank you
how often do you have siamese twins
one side misty
operated and now
one french
one friend
receiver
how often do you have siamese twins here
um
three couple survived
but in the last year we have six couples
but five
was nine one survived okay
very difficult after above
he was dying
his mind functions all right
he can speak japanese
english england english english
french sometimes
japan
what does this hospital in your opinion
need to make
things better
what do you lack
what what don't you have
in the way of equipment or people
equipment
now for the main fog missions
and for the
prevent prevent the rate of metal
missions
we want
the condition
to detect the early in the
pregnant women
to only
make the politician
to reduce the rate of make up mission
very for the result we want to analyze
the
[Music]
level of vaccine in the
patients
of
higher default mode and koryo carcinoma
but
until now because
the one specimen for online
very very expensive you see
two thousand dollars one specimen
before before
three years ago and until now a little
discount fifty percent now one thousand
dollars
one specimen and so we where do you
where is it analyzed
here in vietnam
yes yes in vietnam airlines
directly to french
directly to uh
canada
the specimens are sent to canada they
spent the front to france
where are we going now
in french
air france
air france now has a flight a couple
times a week it's very difficult very
expensive expensive to send the specimen
via air france ah where you come from
come from the united states united
states
watch what city washington dc washington
oh i was in asia 24 hours only
in 1987
for what reason
here
24 hours in washington
you can see all the malformation in
molecule easy statistic i can now what
what is the purpose of this room
why is this here
you can see the
identity pokeballs
these are my commercials
that's uh
are these real fetuses are these these
fetuses were kept after birth or after
an operation
uh no
the pregnant women pregnant but in the
total totals
look like but these like that is a real
fetus yes and about 25 percent
chance
and
if polio carcinoma if severe cases we
cannot
use the
chemotherapy
chemotherapy
if we have not enough the chemotherapy
the ducks the special drugs
what are what are all these
malformations
why did you keep those
first
when were these children how old are
they how old are these fetuses
what year
before before 1975
after
1975 also before and after 1975 yes
but let me ask you again why do you keep
them here at the hospital like this for
studying purposes yeah for not
fostering and and we
keep always some special
typical cases only because we have not
enough
water and not enough for the
formal
to
to keep all the cases and you keep them
do you ever take the fetuses out of the
containers and study them or has that
already been done
in hospital
each year we have about 250 cases of
main focus missions malformation is 250
and then hospital a year yeah several
okay several times of congenital
deformations
okay
simon is doing
left behind hair lips
no arms no legs
and how much of this again do you think
is created by the agent orange
how much of these deformations
was a result of agent orange and the the
toxins and until now very difficult to
to
to conclude
to conclude that
all the midformation
from taxing
effect
one
one part of the main formation can cause
from vaccine
i think that because
in the spray area and the north bay area
the weight in the spray area is much
higher and so we think that right there
is one relation between two books
two areas
[Music]
is there
is that
is that the tour
have we've seen everything we're
supposed to see
uh that is
most of them are very young if you want
we
i think
i would rather not intrude on their
privacy i think we've you know
seen basically what we came to see and i
think it'd probably be better just to
let them if you want to see some
questions and you can
ask ask them if you want the patients
in the spray area come here for
treatment they do the other side where
are they how far away yes okay
[Music]
now what wing of the hospital is this
what's this called this area
this hospital yeah no this this ring
department of chronic diseases
okay
[Music]
how old are the patients that are here
the patients 60 60 best
60 best for the patients of the hydrate
department
but how how old are what's their age how
old
some of them
eat
as a woman but
most of them are very young
md doctor how are you nice to see you
she is the midsection of this service
you can present
some patients
are we sure that it's all right to
i don't want to intrude on these the
last questions
casino
how many
you can see
will you operate on this
this young lady here yes
this is
so it's too late to operate yesterday
do you have here one two three four five
six
yeah seven eight nine ten eleven twelve
thirteen fourteen beds
four rooms three rooms
yeah 24 years old this young lady over
here
this is all women here
yeah
does the heat bother people here hot
does the heat bother
the patients much
yeah
it's it's it's warm
in here
25 years old yes
one child only one time
i don't want to interrupt their lives
anymore that we have i think it's we've
seen enough we'll take after with the
risk to prevent them and to save our
life because
we say that
we can leave masters into the lungs and
sometimes plan and
cannot survive
but the most of them come from the spray
area
from the whey area spray
area spray
spray area
where the agent orange was sprayed most
of them do
but you still haven't been able to prove
that that's cause that have you
if
we have a good condition we can make
the analyze of a
level of dioxin in the spray area
and compared in the nursery area
non-nursery area and we compare
certainly we found out
patients in one bed
two patients in one bed yes sometimes
how often is it
750 bets
but always
over 800 patients
now what is what is this area of the
hospital what do you do here after
operation after operation
this is the operating room in here
this is preparation here
for doctors
it's operating now yes yeah
what kind of an operation is it uh
hope we promote youtube
in this operating room we had operated
the rear end simulation here
okay
[Applause]
[Music]
risk for the women and so we can take
off
how long does this operation take
one year
one one with one hour one hour one hour
where do you where is most of your
equipment from where is it made
what brand names do you use there in the
equipment and the operating equipment
is it is it from france is it ah
germany country
[Music]
very old old
after
1975
we
24 hours
[Music]
it's been a very good tour thank you
dr arnold schechter one of the things
that i noticed when i talk with those
folks is that they all said i think most
of them said that they originally were
from hanoi and it moved down to this
hospital in ho chi minh city in the
south
are they members of the party
well what you observed was that it's
considered highly desirable to
work in the south and in saigon city
it's a plum assignment so it's it's
sought after in that hospital many of
the doctors and nurses are from the
south
but some of the
doctors and nurses from hanoi very much
want to go to that outstanding hospital
and what's your reaction from seeing
this tape have you been to the hospital
by the way i have not been to the
hospital i haven't been to vietnam since
about 1974.
but
the
interesting thing to me is the fact that
although we can't prove it statistically
yet in vietnam
the malformations that you see there
are typical of some of the results that
we've seen
in children of vietnam veterans in this
country
and there's no doubt in my mind that
some fraction
of those
specimens are the result of exposure to
asian orange on the part of the parents
before we go back to dr schechter for
some of the medical questions let me ask
you a political question do you feel
that americans have any responsibility
in vietnam for the effects of agent
orange
well
i think that our tradition has always
been that we
seek to help former enemies
as we did in japan and germany after
world war ii the
the issue with regard to
vietnam is that the people who are
affected by those
diseases of the result of exposure are
just as our boys were innocent people
who were caught up in a war
uh fostered upon them by their communist
leadership
and i think
in the tradition of america binding up
the wounds that
we should work with them and there are
some significant benefits to be gained
for us
through the kind of medical research
that dr schechter and others are doing
by
dealing with this very fine laboratory
example of what happens to humans
exposed to dioxin
all right i didn't should know if you've
just joined us maybe in the middle we
did start off with a conversation with
our two guests admiral zumwalt was chief
of naval operations back in the early
70s i think you still you read a column
today don't you yes among other things
and uh he was also stationed in vietnam
in the late 60s where he ran the
would you call it the brown river navy
or groundwater navy brown water navy
excuse me uh and
as he told us earlier has lost a son who
fought in vietnam
uh
to agent orange or two cancer that uh
you suspect was a was a result of agent
that's correct what years
what year was your son there he was
there at the same time i was from 1969
to 1970 came down with his cancer
actually 13 years later he was one of
the early ones
on the curve it's a little early and the
average period is after 20 years of
exposure 20 years after exposure dr
schechter you're at the state university
of new york at
binghamton right and how long have you
been there 13 years
how much time have you spent in vietnam
and at this hospital over the last
several years i've spent a few weeks in
vietnam every year since 1984 and on
each trip i've worked in this particular
hospital
the you made a comment as we were
watching at the about the public
relations aspect of all this why were we
allowed to do this and would we be
allowed to kick cameras in there
into an operating room for instance in
an american hospital
well
public relations and communication are
now fairly important
to most institutions
the vietnamese observed
[Music]
what they believe is an increase in
cancer an increase in malformations
increase in abortions in people who
lived in the sprayed areas ancient
orange sprayed areas
then they did some
health studies some epidemiology studies
which
were good i think uh in in many cases
not all but in many cases for a
developing country
but would not be
accepted in a western country or more
developed country they need to be redone
they need to be redone now with these
expensive dots and analysis to indicate
who really has exposure and at what
level
and no one was really doing that 10
years ago so this is an area where we
can help each other
we need to know what level of dioxin
causes
cancer reproductive problems immune
deficiency
because dioxins are now very common in
america and other industrial countries
not only from agent orange for municipal
incinerators paper and pulp bleaching
smelting of certain things pcb
transformer fires the food we eat
contains certain levels of
dioxin
so it's it's very important that we
learn uh by helping each other
at what level there needs to be concern
and at what level of exposure perhaps we
don't need to worry so much for american
veterans and for others in our
population let me ask the question that
probably people who are
you know have watched this and said
c-span got duped they took their cameras
into the hospital they walked around and
saw
deformed children and women with cancer
in the ward and these bottles of fetuses
in it and they didn't really answer the
question and this really isn't agent
orange and all that at the bottom of all
this can you blame what we saw on agent
orange
i think the answer that you got
repeatedly was they believe the
physicians you were talking to
that a certain percent of the
malformations and the cancers were
caused by agent orange but they did tell
you that there were other causes they
talked about malnutrition i didn't hear
them talk about infectious diseases but
when i'm there we go over the various
causes
we believe that agent orange and dioxin
based on the published literature from
other countries in animals and in people
probably is likely to have contributed
to a certain percent of the problems you
saw not not
i would guess as a physician who's
worked in the area not the high
detidiform mole and cardio carcinoma but
other cancers
some male formations some neurologic
problems some immune deficiency or the
inability to fight infection some
learning disabilities there's an
interesting dichotomy here those doctors
are probably under some pressure
from their government to overstate the
case and i thought they did a pretty
good job of being balanced
in this country
those who are subject to government
pressure are under pressure to come up
just the reverse conclusions
the the government policy in our country
has been
to
understate the risks of exposure to
dioxin
what about the current political
situation in this country regarding
agent orange how many lawsuits are there
and what kind of liability does the
government have well there's a major
lawsuit going on again being brought
against the government by the
american legion and another organization
of veterans
on the basis that the study that
congress dictated statutorily be done
to analyze
the the result of exposure to asian
orange was never
well done it wasn't done at all as a
matter of fact
and
my i would anticipate
that in time that
litigation will lead to a court decision
that the government must do that study
meanwhile i should report that
we're always a
government of interest groups in this
country the chemical companies the paper
companies bring immense pressure to bear
and spend millions of dollars of
lobbying effort to
seek to deny a finding that dioxin is
carcinogenic or has other health effects
but at the same time
people like me and the veterans groups
are trying very hard to get an objective
decision made
i can report that this administration is
the first that has
taken a serious look at it and this
president and this secretary of veterans
affairs
have have now
issued formal findings that there are
four health effects that are the result
of exposure to asian orange
so we are making progress uh back to
this hospital that we saw um
it's hard one of the things that we
feel inadequate to do for the audience
is you can't
you can't transmit the smell you can't
transmit the feeling of the heat and you
also can't show
the cleanliness or lack thereof explain
from what you're used to and seeing this
hospital in your own medical practice
how is this how is this hospital kept
the hospital was is one of the most
impressive hospitals for vietnam however
in vietnam
it is a third world country it's a
developing country one of the poorest
countries in the world and most
americans would be shocked by the
hospitals of vietnam
by everything you commented on and as
well as the the living standards that
most people
have
nevertheless
it offers the opportunity to do the
studies
vietnam and these hospitals offer the
opportunity to do the health studies
which admiral zumwalt mentioned
the largest population of agent orange
exposed people in the world for the
longest period of time in vietnam in the
south and in the north there are people
with
very low exposures so we have an ideal
health laboratory to study
and it's it's my hope that
the congressionally mandated health
studies will be funded
through american medical schools and
schools of public health in vietnam to a
certain extent can you shed some light
on the siamese twin that we saw
and why is that they seem to keep
referring to it why was that such an
important thing for them
well the siamese twins
which they believe they're seeing in
higher levels than you would expect in
the south of vietnam they wonder if this
might be an agent orange effect but i
think it goes beyond that the symbolism
that they've kept
siamese twins alive and done a
magnificent job surgically of separating
some of these nearly impossible to
separate cases
viet and duke the two
brothers who they described to you where
they did 13 or 14 or 15 hours worth of
surgery in that hospital
uh that was
right that was magnificent surgery and
uh
it was really world-class surgery
despite the fact that they they lack the
cancer drugs and they lack everything
else they were describing to you
is it hard for you to keep talking about
this
no
the
the death of our son is now sufficiently
past that
we remember the happy times and have
gotten over the
horrifying times
and both my wife and i feel that
a fine living memorial to our sun is the
work that we do
to try to press forward this government
on making the additional decisions on
the other health effects
caused by exposure to asian orange and i
also chair the national marrow donor
program which has recruited 600 000
americans
to volunteer to give marrow to those
cancer patients who are terminal many of
whom will be vietnam veterans are there
any numbers to not the percentages but
total numbers of people that you that
served in the united states military
that may be affected by agent orange
well i think uh
the the way to come at it is as follows
if if one expected
uh that
normally there would be one out of
every thousand who are going to have
come down with a cancer in the normal
group
as a result of the exposure to asian
orange it's likely to be six or eight
out of a thousand it's not everybody who
is exposed but it's a six or eight fold
increase if one goes by for example what
we learned about kansas farmers exposed
to 24d one of the one of the components
of agent orange you were there for a
couple of years is there any concern
with you that you might come up with
agent well cancer with all this dr
scheckter has been after me for years to
get a fat test to discover how much
dioxin i might have in my system i was
exposed because i was out in the sprayed
areas every day
i have some of the symptoms that i
suppose
could be related to exposure to agent
orange but they also could be related to
old age
so i i'm not worrying about them if you
don't mind me asking how old are you i'm
71.
and are you you active every day yes i
still do a three mile run every day
why do you
go through the uh
the difficulty i guess you could
describe it if going all the way over to
vietnam it's a 30-hour trip door-to-door
and
it's hot and the facilities there aren't
what you're used to here and you do this
every year what is what's in it for you
well i think we're at an exciting time
in medicine
remember a few hundred years ago we
didn't know that there was such a thing
as a heart attack or that there was such
a diseases appendicitis
now we've got these synthetic chemicals
in our environment dioxin is symbolic of
a chemical that's almost exclusively
from industry what do these chemicals do
to us how do we measure them
uh at what level do we need to be
concerned
and
we're never going to get a better
opportunity just as admiral zumwalt
described
the american learning experience in
japan after the atomic bomb where
americans in japanese work together to
learn what are radiation effects we're
never going to have a better shot at
learning what the effect of dioxins are
in humans than we have right now while
the levels are still elevated in many
vietnamese and are not elevated in
others
to learn what levels do cause cancer
reproductive problems immune deficiency
learning disability and so on we're
going to have by the way the addresses
of both gentlemen on the screen so that
you can write them if you want to
contact them and we don't have a whole
lot of time left you want to say
something i just want to point out that
a recent study done by dr fingerhut of
the government agency niosh
which examined 5172
workers in 12 chemical companies in this
country found that there was a 15
increase in cancers overall as compared
to normal
and that for those workers who had been
exposed for a year
and had had 20 years of latency there
was a 46 increase so i think the answer
is now pretty definitive about what
dioxin does let me get just a little bit
of biographical information here people
always want to know where you're from
where is home originally where did you
go to medical school and how long have
you been at suny being in binghamton
i grew up in chicago went to the
university of chicago howard medical
school here in washington harvard post
doctoral work
served in the u.s army medical corps
where i was drafted during the vietnam
war but didn't go to vietnam
and
taught at a number of medical schools in
the east including harvard
and for the last 13 years i've been at
what we call the clinical campus of suny
health science center syracuse located
in binghamton
admiral zuma where's home i grew up in
the san joaquin valley of california a
little town called tulare i was the
second of four children born to
a mother and father both of whom were
doctors and
so i've been close to the medical
profession all my life
and did a lot of work with medical
officers as i came up through the navy
and uh did you did you go to the u.s
naval academy i graduated from the naval
academy in 1942 just in time to get into
the solomon's campaign of that war and
served in the korean war and of course
in vietnam war
what about the big issue of
vietnam and should we still be you know
we've devoted a lot of hours to this is
there something that's still in our
system as a country that we need to work
out
any opinions doctor well the the
veterans who i've seen going to vietnam
seem to frequently find it a catharsis
to go back
and see vietnam as a country and a
people not as a war
and i think
we tend to have a fixation of a certain
time in history that's long since over
vietnam's a country of 70 million people
almost all of whom would like to have
closer ties with the united states
and
i think it's probably to our advantage
for a number of reasons whether
economically emotionally socially
or
to learn about
agent orange and dioxin to extend our
knowledge
just two quick points at the uh at the
very
minute level
uh two of the five members of my son's
crew in vietnam have come down with
cancers one one other besides my son
another two of the five have
had post traumatic stress disorders
those are very high percentages
not a revert to a completely different
area the policy level i think that it's
clear that our government is moving
toward recognition of the vietnam
government
the the vietnamese i think have done a
reasonably good job now of satisfying
that there are no remaining pows over
there and they worked with us to get a
settlement in cambodia i think the time
is coming close and ought to be soon
when we recognize
that government
do you see many veterans on your trips
back
yes i almost always find american
vietnam veterans
over in vietnam as a healing experience
for most of them
back to the hospital for a little bit
you know the the little children on the
floor
uh
is that is that an uh was that is that a
surprise and is that a a clean thing to
do i i heard you know it's kind of a
dumb question maybe but when i saw it it
was a little bit of a surprise they were
posed for you of course i mean they're
not normally on a floor the floor was
very clean that was a model unit donated
by a german charity that to build that
building
they were there for communication
purpose and why would they put them on
the floor
i'm not sure that that was the
the wisest way to
establish the
public relations point that they were
trying to make but
they thought that that was a natural
place for children perhaps
what else do you think they did
specifically for us
yeah again what's their goal
and is it uh do you find it were you
cynical about what they did oh no no i
think uh not cynical at all uh if if one
is a physician
uh sees um
malformed babies and sees cancer in
excess of what you believe is
as usual i think it's very important to
report this to communicate it they were
they were
they were using you of course but
in a in a good way i think they were
trying to say that we believe some of
the agent orange effects are malformed
babies in our cancer
and we want you to visually see this and
it's it's easier to convey a picture by
seeing a patient by seeing a human being
they showed you some
published research paper but
that obviously is
going to put a television audience to
sleep
they showed you both they showed you
their evidence in
human beings and they showed you written
evidence
uh i think there is other evidence from
the national cancer institute from the
uh nih
national institute environmental health
perspective that suggests that what
their they think they see is
biologically plausible last question to
both of you uh people watching say i
want to do something and i'd ask you
this about the hospital
because you off frequently get people
say i want to adopt one of those
children for instance or are you a
veteran out there saying
you know i don't know where to go about
the way i feel about agent orange or
what would you recommend to him i
recommend that the raw naked power of
public opinion be organized by veterans
writing to their congressmen and their
senators to get additional health
effects from exposure to asian orange
authorized for compensation and i would
recommend that everybody write their
congressmen and senators
to insist that the epa standards on
dioxin
not be
made
less safe there is a study going on at
the present time which uh as of the
present shows that if anything the
dioxin standards ought to be tightened
up
and i would second what uh admiral
zumwalt said i think it's essential
that the public communicate to
their elected officials that it is time
to reopen the asian orange and dioxin
human health studies and it's essential
to exploit the knowledge that we can
only get in vietnam and
american medical school schools of
public health as well as the federal
government should all be involved that
way there can be no
even appearance of a conflict of
interest government
to government we've got a lot of talent
in american medical schools let's work
back and forth with the vietnamese and
and get the answers that we're
slowly getting by not using vietnam by
the way do you like the vietnamese that
you meet with over there
well
i like some people and i don't like
others they're the same as in this
country there's some very likable people
some very admirable people and in every
country there's some people you'd rather
not see again last last question about
contacting what they saw if they want if
somebody wanted to do something about
anything they saw at that hospital what
would be the best way to go
well if they want to write me i'll be
happy to to write back
not sure that there's an efficient way
of communicating between the countries
just yet do you intend to ever go back
again yes i'd like to i've been invited
several times
and the government felt that it was too
early for me to go back but at some
point i would
in order to try to expedite this process
that dr schechter has just recommended
the the use of that laboratory data
admiral elmo zumwalt former chief of
naval operations and dr arnold schechter
professor researcher at the department
of preventative medicine college of
medicine at the state university of new
york at binghamton thank you both very
much for your time thank you vietnam
revisited continues
and continues with reid irvine chairman
of the board of accuracy and media mr
irvine
after this ran in
may or over memorial day you wrote us a
letter saying uh there's another side of
this story about agent orange you want
to just take that and run with it
yeah i've been uh interested in the
agent orange problem since the days of
the vietnam war at that time
agent orange was such an effective uh
tool to use against the enemy and
denying the cover
that they
were getting out of the jungle
that the communists began a very
intensive campaign worldwide campaign
to try to disarm us to take this weapon
away from us
and the
stories were spread at that time through
their international propaganda network
that this was a
a very dangerous chemical it was causing
all kinds of birth defects and
illnesses and so they were appealing on
humanitarian grounds in part they were
also
contending
that this was
going to permanently destroy the forests
and the jungles which was not true
and
so at that time being accuracy in media
we were interested in combating the
disinformation being put out by the the
communists
um
the campaign succeeded in that the
nixon administration decided that they
would discontinue the use of
after they'd only used it for
something over a year
uh two or three years i don't remember
exactly now but it was a fairly
relatively short period of time
and
so it was discontinued
but the
the propaganda continued and it reached
this country
in the early 1970s
there was a
veterans administration employee in
chicago
who got the idea and i don't know to
what extent she may have been influenced
by the propaganda coming out of vietnam
that
exposure to asian orange might explain
the illnesses of
veterans in this country
and
she began
working on that line and it it was
originally promoted by
the wbbm a television station in chicago
that
did a series
contending that indeed agent orange was
causing serious illnesses cancer and
other things
now there are always people
who are very eager to find some reason
to explain their illnesses something
that they can sue on they can get
compensation for
so this
became a popular cause among some
veterans
suffering a variety of
illnesses
many of which could not have possibly
had any connection with agent orange but
it was became something that they could
claim
disability benefits for
actually the veterans administration
could find very few people very few
veterans that had
the one
symptom of agent orange that exposure to
dioxin would cause namely chloracne it's
a skin a
and there are only a handful of cases of
anyone who'd served in vietnam who came
who came up with chloracne
so on the surface it appeared unlikely
that
having not had
this common symptom of exposure you were
going to get a very large number of
people who were
suffering from
cancer or
other ailments that might have been
caused by the exposure
now the people who were engaged in
in spraying
agent orange
the ranch hand group as it's called
there are about 1200 of them all
together
and
they
when the pressure became very strong for
contending that agent orange was causing
illnesses
the air force began
to study the these veterans because they
had had the most the heaviest exposure
of all uh oftentimes uh they would
they they'd take fire from the ground
the
tubing would
become damaged they'd become soaked in
agent orange
colonel hobbs whom i became acquainted
with who headed the ranch hand
detachment for a while
used to demonstrate what he considered
to be at safety by slurping the stuff
for the benefit of journalists to assure
them was safe
and
so they studied the ranch hand they've
been studying the ranch hand giving them
intensive physical examinations for many
years now
and they could find no increased
mortality uh
in comparison with the control group
and they could find no increased
illnesses
now the latest
survey the latest
examinations did reveal some elevation
of kidney disease
among the group that had been exposed
and they've been able to
to
refine the studies because now they can
test for the actual
level of dioxin in the fatty tissues of
the body so they can find out which
subjects have
had a lot of dioxin exposure because
they still can
that would still be some
traces of it in the body
and so that has permitted an additional
refinement
by and large the there is no evidence in
the ranch hand studies
that
increased or heavy exposure to heavier
exposure that the ranch had people got
had it had resulted in any increased
ailments the ranch hand people were the
people that flew the planes the flu
people that flew the planes loaded the
asian orange on the plains right
let me read dr schechter couldn't be
here today um and let me just read a
short paragraph that he wrote in
response to your letter to us on this
issue of the ranch hands maybe it's i
must tell the audience it's very
difficult this stuff is so difficult
and and the information is voluminous
it's hard to deal with too much of it or
will get lost
he wrote back he said the ranch hand
sprayers are a relatively small group
about 1200 in number some are not
participating and some had very low
dioxin levels so only a portion had high
intake
there has not been a long latency time
for all cancer elevations to develop
if it is going to do so with such a
small sample size as noted by the
researchers the power of the study to
find an increase in
in rare events as an increase in soft
tissue sarcoma for example is very low
some excess cancer endocrine
disorders
lipid metabolism abnormalities etc have
been noted it is only very recently that
actual dioxin levels to estimate
exposure have been used and so far only
two three seven eight tcdd i have no
idea what they're talking about has been
carefully elevated uh evaluated not
total dioxin body burden the air force
researchers strongly recommend further
research to determine uh research to
determine the extent of health effects
well
the
of course the number of uh
ranch handlers was small compared to the
total number of people that served in
vietnam
but i think the point is
that they were the group that you do
definitely know had exposure to agent
orange and dioxin
the problem with doing
there was some criticism in the
program that you aired
that
the veterans administration had not done
the as congress had mandated studies of
the veterans that were you know the
general run of veterans that were
exposed
and uh the reason that the veterans
administration and indeed in in the end
to see the centers for disease control
was took over the
mandate to do that study the reason i
couldn't i couldn't do the kinds of
studies that science would require was
because there was no way of telling
what the what veterans had been exposed
and which ones hadn't as colonel hobbes
explained to me he said the a lot of
people that he would talk to they they
thought they had been sprayed by agent
orange when they'd been
sprayed by insecticides around the camp
and
they used a different uh
colored plane to do that to do the
insecticides but the the troops on the
ground didn't know that
so the uh when you compare the possible
and moreover you have to understand that
agent orange was not being sprayed over
our troops they were being sprayed over
the enemy troops out in the jungles
so the the body burdens of dioxin in the
normal veterans was very low in any
cases i say there were
even among the ranch handers there was
very little uh chloracne and among those
in general there were only two or three
cases actually got to open the phones up
if i remember correctly accuracy in the
media is starting in 69 69. are 23 years
ago right
let's take a call jacksonville florida
go ahead please
uh yeah so i was
a vietnam veteran i draw 100 disability
for uh jungle run of both feet and post
traumatic stress disorder and i have a
lot of problems with blood clots with my
legs
and during operation
dewey canyon in 1969
in the ashaw valley
we were sprayed directly
with agent orange and it turned green
bamboo overnight into black
just mush and laid it over on the ground
a lot of us had a lot of problems
a couple days later with a lot of skin
rashes and burning a lot of blistering
of the feet and the hands
and you go to the va hospital
and in three different occasions bay
pines florida
johnson city tennessee and fayetteville
north carolina i've had doctors
close the door behind me and tell me if
they put agent orange on my records
they'll lose their job
and i just don't think it's right we're
not doing enough to
find out what the
effects of this are thank you sir well
you've described
you said skin rashes and that is an
indication of exposure to
agent oranges and as chloracne as i said
but it's not a it's not a serious
disease it's it's like it's something
that you will get over and will not give
you any
lifetime problems
the
the charges that have been made relate
to really on the basis of
animal tests uh clinical clinical tests
with animals that agent oranges or the
dioxin is the most potent toxin
man-made toxin
ever created
and
that was on the basis of the fact that
is some animals guinea pigs for example
are extremely sensitive to dioxin
other animals laboratory rats for
example are not
and
in human beings we do have
cases where large numbers of human
beings have been exposed to dioxin
there was a very large
chemical explosion in cerveza italy in
1976
it was estimated that some 250 000
people were exposed to dioxin as a
result of that explosion
and
they've been watching that population uh
ever since that's now a period of
of uh
what 20
20 16 years
and
there have been no
no evidence of any serious
diseases long-term diseases have
resulted from that
similarly there was a an accident in
nitro west virginia in a plant even
earlier back in the 40s and again
no increased mortality from those
epidemiological studies
now let me just cite one more brian the
the
there was a study made by niosh a
researcher by the name of fingerhood
came out a couple of years ago
a very long term study of workers in
chemical plants
that were exposed to
dioxin through their work
and they found there that the
those that had had less than one year
exposure
uh no
no long-term ill effects
those that had
exposures
of
in greater than one year
one to five years and over 20 years
after a 20
20 year latency period did show elevated
incidents of cancer but the peculiar
thing about this study those that had
exposures from five to twenty years
no uh elevation of cancer so it was not
a straight line so there's a
the one interpretation of that study is
that it uh it indicated that dioxin
indeed wasn't the serious problem been
thought and it led
dr vernon houck of the centers for
disease control
to reverse his judgment that he made
back in 1980 that dioxin was such a
serious problem such a serious threat
that the government had to buy up the
town of times beach missouri where
contaminated oil contaminated docks had
been spread on the roads to leave to lay
the dust they bought up the whole town
and moved everybody out because they
thought it was such a terrible problem
and 10 years later after these studies
had been been made
dr halk reversed himself and said that
was a mistake and it shouldn't have been
done
vietnam revisited continues for the next
three hours and five minutes today there
will be two more days of this on
thursday and friday thursday is devoted
to economics friday is devoted to a trip
throughout vietnam with the mia pow
select committee in the senate reed
irvine will be with us for another 15
minutes trenton new jersey go ahead
please hi uh brian first of all i wanted
to thank you for c-span and for all your
work um thank you this uh this series
has been excellent and your presidential
coverage has been excellent and your
network is a reason why we have cable tv
i wanted to say that while i appreciate
c-span's effort to be fair in terms of
bringing this man's opinion and his
group's opinion i find his opinion
reprehensible and bizarre in light of so
much of the other testimony and the
other studies and i don't think he does
the service by selectively citing
pieces of data that he wants to cite to
make his case and i think there's
certainly enough on the record to
warrant
a lot more study into this and i guess i
would have two questions and then i'm
going to hang up by the way let me ask
you do you do you have a experience with
vietnam related
sickness no i actually don't and the
reason i'm i mean i sort of felt bad
about taking time because i thought
they're probably vets who do who are
trying to call in i've been i'm a
longtime newspaper journalist and i've
i've read a lot and written stories at
certain points um about veterans in this
state
and the studies that are being done here
and so on
um there was a study out of rutgers a
few years ago that that was being done
that found plenty of reason to keep
looking into it but i don't have any
first hand experience hold on just a
second do you think that they should
continue to research it oh of course
there's no no problem with continuing
and it will go on being researched
all we can do is say what the
what the results are to date the results
to date
indicate and i think there is not a
unanimity in the scientific community
but certainly there is a
some consensus on the part of a large
part of the community at least
that
dioxin has been given a bum wrap
and
there's another aspect to this that the
the thinking now is that
the mechanism by which dioxin affects
living organisms is based on
i can't go into the whole thing a
receptor mechanism in the cell
and
there's a threshold
uh beyond which or below which
it has no effect
and
so this is why a lot of scientists who
who are now into this into this aspect
this theory
believe that it is the limits that have
been placed on
dioxin exposure by the epa in this
country are
are
much too low that there's uh
much too cautious other countries have
higher levels
and
and this is based on the threshold
theory trenton uh go ahead with your
questions i didn't mean to interrupt two
quick questions
um number one
would you be willing or have you been
willing or have you had family members
who have been exposed to dioxin number
one and number two what is your bottom
line
concern about the way this has been
presented are you concerned that the
government is going to end up spending
too much or what is your bottom line
concern and those are my two questions
thank you very much thanks for your call
i've had no personal exposure nor
uh have any members of my family i did
mention that
my friend colonel charlie hobbs who was
one of the leader of the ranch hand
detachment
uh was so confident that of its safety
that he used to slurp the stuff to
demonstrate its safety for the benefit
of journalists
there is
you know there just hasn't been over the
years
any
any good epidemiological evidence that
would suggest that
the fears that have been created by the
propaganda about this thing are
justified
the
so the
you know there's a lot of waste we've
we've expended a lot of money in this
country for example in the paper
industry
in order to eliminate from
the waste products for paper mills
perhaps a half a cupful of dioxin
in the entire united states
in the affluent because the amounts are
very small
billions of dollars have been spent to
improve the
processing of paper to try to get rid of
this chemical it isn't something that
you know it's not just agent orange
dioxin is present
as a result of a lot of processes it's
it's an ingredient
or it's a it's a contaminant that people
don't want
and they've tried very hard to eliminate
it and minimize its presence
but it's been very difficult to do chico
california for read irvine
yeah i have a question
i just tried to say i was aware of
vietnam and they were using it on the
road base for the rock on the road ql-13
uh doesn't that go back into the water
system and uh i know where the water was
coming from when we were picking it up
at the camp so uh did you have any
any reaction to what you think was agent
orange oh most definitely uh the fact is
i've just got on the suit on the uh one
in new york and they just paid me 1800
for a year uh which is pretty ridiculous
uh what kind of uh what kind of impact
did it have on you physically physically
i'm rashes on my eyes and my tailbone
spits open right at the bottom of the
base of my
tailbone in my spine it splits open like
every month there's a the acid comes out
uh i've had headaches to where you know
i've been in the hospital like four or
five times and it's you know they've
even agreed to it they said that they
can't do much about him with problems
with my kids and everything else but
they agree that there definitely is
problems
mr irvine
well you know veterans
from all wars and all times have had
problems health problems
i'm a veteran of world war ii
fortunately i i haven't had any problems
that i can blame on my service or
fortunately but many have where were you
in world war ii i was in the pacific in
the marine corps
in saipan in the jungles
now the um
you know i can't diagnose this
gentleman's case he refers to the suit
you know there was a class action suit
against the government that was settled
back in i guess was 1983
and the judge in that case judge jack
weinstein advised the veterans and their
lawyers who were bringing the suit to
accept the settlement
there was an offer from the chemical
companies the seven chemical companies
that were the
the defendants because they had been the
chemical companies that produced agent
orange
and the judge said advised the
defendants that they had better accept
this settlement because
there was no scientific evidence to
that would justify the claims being made
by the veterans
now
a large sum of money i think uh
the figure was something like 180
million dollars was
was
awarded
now there were a large number of
veterans and this then became a big
problem this veteran said he only got 18
1800 dollars
once the award was granted the veterans
who were contesting it began fighting
among themselves because then it became
a question of who is going to get the
money
and how is it going to be determined
well since there's no scientific
evidence to determine who who had been
actually damaged by agent orange
there were all kinds of claimants people
that had
illnesses that couldn't possibly be
related to agent orange who were on the
same basis as people who had claims that
they might have a soft tissue sarcoma
which there was some evidence that
dioxin might might be a cause of soft
tissues are coming in that that may not
just say in the letter that we got back
from
dr schechter from
the state university at binghamton he
says judge weinstein and the agent
orange settlement was in 1984. there has
been an enormous amount of scientific
work since then for instance the air
force has recently published findings of
increased diabetes and increased blood
lipids in the ranch hand agent orange
sprayers related to the dose of dioxins
dioxin from agent oranges determined
from blood dioxin analysis prefirmed at
perform at the centers for disease
control he goes on with a lot longer
answer than that
well i mentioned that in the in the
latest uh series of ranch hand
examinations they did have uh find that
there were some elevated
incidents of
of kidney trouble
whether or not that's related to
directly related to the exposures is
still uncertain
uh
the
but the uh
i would i've of course since 1984 that's
eight years
eight years ago there has been
additional research that's gone on but
the additional research has gone on has
not
uh turned up any
uh evidence that i'm aware of and that
the people that i'm not the
final expert in these things but i've
been in touch with some people who are
following it very closely that would uh
suggest that
indeed this
wide range of illnesses were caused by
agent orange
bran let me just say one other thing
admiral zumwalt was on the program his
son
came down with lymphoma he was
in the navy and he served on the on the
naval vessels on the rivers
one anomaly that came when the cdc
studied this problem
centers for disease disease control
what they did was take a large number of
vietnam veterans and they matched them
up with veterans
who had served in the same period but
not in vietnam where there was no
possibility of exposure to agent orange
now they couldn't tell which vietnam
veterans had been exposed which hadn't
so they just took vietnam veterans in
general
and what they came up with was no
greater incidence of illness or
mortality among the vietnam veterans
and the
and the others for cancer they were
testing for cancer
no no increased incidence of cancer
except for lymphoma
but the anomaly was that the lymphoma
was
elevated lymphoma was among
naval personnel who had served aboard
ships and had not been exposed to agent
orange which would be the case with
admirals and walt's son
he wasn't on the river patrol
he was on the river patrol but you know
they were not being they're not spraying
directly i mean
i talked to admiral zumwalt years ago at
the time and they said well yeah but
they you know they'd get out and swim in
the streams and this stuff might be
washing down and so on but there was no
direct exposure to the spraying let me
grab a call if you don't mind because
they've been waiting for a long time
agustic georgia go ahead please
yes i would like to ask mr irvin
or irvine
only one single question
would you be willing
to step into a bathtub filled with
ancient orange and take a bath in it
as i uh as i indicated sir there is
there is one symptom that they have
discovered from heavy exposure to this
chemical and that's chloracne and quite
frankly i'm not anxious to get any skin
rashes
but
as far as
the exposure i think i would be willing
to do what
charlie hobbs did as far as i know he's
still in good health
after all these years and i'd be willing
to stick my thumb in a
in a glass and slurp it if that would
satisfy you that i have confidence that
it is not the dire
poison that has been portrayed to be
we're going to take a tour of the
prosthetic center in saigon in a few
moments and that's the center that was
started by a doctor in seattle
independence ohio your next and last
call for reed irvine go ahead please hi
mr irvine i ran into one of your
fundraisers in houston at the convention
he was complaining that there was no
healthy food at the convention
my question for you first let me say
that i have a friend who is dead of
agent orange according to the doctors at
the veterans hospital in cleveland
and
in response to what you said about nitro
west virginia if you look at
cancer incidence maps of the united
states you will see that nitro has one
of the highest cancer incidence rates in
the country for all types of cancer
my my question
relates to the ethics
not only in terms of human beings but
to the massive echo destruction of a
whole
environmental system in south vietnam
and north vietnam all the trees all the
birds all the
rare species all the
the
disregard of all forms of life which
was involved in defoliating so many
thousands of acres
first of all i didn't have any
fundraisers in houston so i don't know
who it was you meant but
the
nitro west virginia may indeed have a
high cancer rate there are places in
right near washington dc that also have
high cancer rates it doesn't necessarily
mean that it has anything to do with
agent orange or dioxin
the
as far as the ecosystem i mentioned
earlier that this was one of the claims
that had been put out by the
disinformation propaganda that this was
going to destroy the forests
and the national academy of sciences
commissioned a major study on this
back in the 70s
and their conclusion was that the there
was no permanent damage to the hardwood
forest in the interior
they said that there was a uh
long-term damage to the mangrove uh
trees along in the um
in the low-lying areas on the coast
and it was estimated it would probably
take 20-25 years to restore the mangrove
forest but that was the
that was the total sum total of the
study done by the national academy of
sciences
we've got about a minute left
calls are
finished our calls
a lot of emotion during a week like this
from our callers
how much longer do you think the vietnam
war
will
impact this country
well it's uh it'll
probably until we have another war and
it's our last
our last major war and
and it's going to be with us for a long
time there's a lot of misunderstanding
there's a lot of bad feeling
we've got in the presidential campaign
over bill clinton's dodging the draft
during vietnam incidentally there's a
major story on that in the los angeles
times this morning which i know you as a
broad reader of newspapers undoubtedly
saw but haven't read that
additional evidence that indeed very
strenuous measures were taken to
enable him to avoid being drafted in
vietnam and
we only got 10 seconds should and i this
isn't fair to ask this question should
the united states lift the economic
embargo
against vietnam
i
i think when vietnam makes
greater efforts to solve some of the
problems that we have with them that
that might be the case right now i don't
think they're making those efforts reid
irvine chairman of accuracy and media
here to talk about agent orange thank
you very much thank you brian
as you might remember over the memorial
day run of this first vietnam revisited
special we had a response line we
listened to a lot of you on tape
and we got some 3 000 calls and here are
some of those responses
for
that we got for you to listen to and
we'll be back with uh some more open
phones
i have been
very impressed by the c-span programming
on vietnam however my question is
to what regard was a book kiss the boys
goodbye by monica jensen stevenson and
william stevenson regarded
as
impetus for a program of this nature i
would just like to say that a lot of the
film
has to do with hanoi and very
very few americans decided the prisoners
were in hanoi is there any more film on
south vietnam where the make or the
americans were based and where their
actual battles and firefights were i'm
kind of curious about the garwoods uh
how about those that just simply
don't want to come back the ones that
stayed there and uh
do whatever means and uh they just chose
not to be uh identified and wanted to
stay there what about that um i wonder
if anybody could throw some light on the
fate of
uh military personnel who went across
the border with no id
then come back are they included on the
pow mia list
very curious about what the defense
department is doing about pilots shot
down in vietnam who may have been
shipped to russia
my friend cliff cushman
was shot down 925-66
flying a delta dagger and i believe he
was shipped through india to russia i
have a question regarding the prison
that the senators are currently shown
visiting
obviously we tried to get into that
prison before and had been refused
access so the vietnamese could have
guessed that we would try to get in
again um so i didn't expect any live
prisoners to be found but
were anything found on the cell walls or
any any indication that there were
americans held there at one time i'd
like to ask about the possibility of
some of these uh prisoners pows becoming
sympathetic to the vietnamese and
staying on seeking political asylum
i am a sister of a pow
and i don't like the comment that mr
solomon made about bobby garwood
staying there on his own he was a
prisoner of war
he has information this government
deliberately
tore that man's life apart
and there are still like pows in them in
m.i.a in southeast asia
and the government should bring them
home they left them there they should
bring my brother home
what you see on your screen is in hanoi
as was the last video that uh was played
behind the responses from some of our
viewers that's a locksmith believe it or
not doing business
independently right there on the streets
in hanoi that's very close to where some
of you may have seen earlier in the week
the video of the barber street which is
right around the corner
this man i asked him to
show us how he did his work and he grabs
the key there as you'll see and pounds
it out so he can give us some indication
of
how he makes his living we're going to
have the phones open here for a few
moments i might tell you if you've just
joined us you're watching
what says right there on the screen
vietnam revisited it came from a trip
that c-span took jim mills is our
producer assisted by jacqueline pham
greg gursky and richard weinstein are
camera people that went over there and
shot most of what you're seeing
this was done in april the trip started
on the 18th of april from bangkok to
hanoi a couple of days in hanoi then
down to saigon and then on to the mekong
delta mekong delta footage will be run
here on c-span on friday starting at
noon east coast time and going until
five in the afternoon
following the mia pow's select committee
in the senate
who
will be out of business january 3rd
expected
more hearings september 21st 22nd and
23rd henry kissinger is slated to
testify
about the peace paris peace corps
negotiations that went on back in the
70s and there were hearings in april and
in november and possibly a return trip
on the part of the committee
senator john kerry chairman senator
smith co-chairman vice chairman of the
committee and they might go back to
vietnam again in november let's grab
this call from savannah georgia go ahead
please
hi savannah you're on the air
yes
i find it quite objectionable that uh
he
your previous guest reed irvine yes sir
uh
portrayed the fact that agent orange was
not a carcinogen
because my i myself have lung cancer
from this how long have you had it sir
uh for about
a year and a half and has it been proven
that it was caused by agent
orange well they can't prove it but i do
not smoke
i have been to the va about this
through every agency and no one wants to
admit this
and i i just feel like that you know
he is
that he's an agent of the government
trying to get out of
to get out of
the basic problems of
of the vietnam war when were you in
vietnam sir
69 through 73 or four years
oh yes and what service
i was in the navy in the navy off the
coast or in the river
river patrol
all right thanks a lot for calling
parsippany new jersey you're next oh
okay you're on the air
i'm on the air now yes sir right now
okay
go ahead what's your comment
brian yes sir oh my god i couldn't
believe it
for a year
sorry i wasn't
i'm a vietnam veteran
and uh
i listened to all this stuff and you
know i i had a small problem with aiden
orange i don't i don't think it could be
a major problem i had like a
rash in my in my crotch and stuff and it
went away but uh
watching that stuff and it's upsetting
to me i mean uh are you are you disabled
from the vietnam war no i didn't file at
all or nothing you know
what are you doing now
well
i work i mean got a job oh yeah when you
look when you look back at this war what
comes to what do you think about it
well just
it all comes back does it i mean uh
what service are you in i was in the
navy
uh from 63 to 69. and where were you
stationed in vietnam when you were there
well all over
uh how long were you there
well all together about uh 23 25 months
we were
it was from 19 i went in 1963
and i was just charging 69.
um
should we i'm real nervous about this
that's all right uh you're doing fine
should we in your opinion
restore relations with vietnam
see that's that's that's the hard part i
got
i
can almost understand where they're
coming from
and understand where we're coming from
i got a lot of problems with the
mia pw thing and
you think there's anybody left there
alive
yeah in my heart i think so
but thinking about it i'm not sure all
right thanks a lot for calling by the
way kirtland air force base new mexico
go ahead please hello hi you're on the
air
yes i
wanted to talk comment on this cnn
program on vietnam you mean c-span
yeah
and my husband was a kc-135 pilot which
is
what like a 707 a big tanker a jet
tanker
and he had was over flying i think out
of thailand at that time he flew 90 day
missions for three years over vietnam
and
he one of the hosts broke from the
planes that they were loading with the
defoliant at one time and he got
defoliant all over him um
he only he we didn't even know the agent
orange at that time but um he went back
to where he was staying and he lost
about 20 pounds he had diarrhea and
vomiting for
a couple weeks after that so he was
critically ill
and then as he came home he started
getting gross all over him
they went on a differential diagnosis
for three years and ultimately he died
of a non-hodgkin's lymphoma called
mycosis fungitis
did they connect it directly to the
defoliant absolutely connected to the
defoliant did you were you rewarded any
anything by the government because of it
no i i had filed a claim because i
thought maybe it could help other people
substantiate their claims as they named
it agent orange but they said i had to
prove all the bases that he flew out of
et cetera et cetera and i didn't have
accurate documentation
i they had taken hundreds of pictures
out at mass general hospital in boston
massachusetts
and
they could file for the pictures to see
all the growth and things that came on
his skin there was
certainly plenty of documentation on how
this the condition developed
but i when it first happened i thought
he came home with leprosy and as i said
the growth evolved
it painted almost the same picture of
what admiral zumwalt's son went through
all right thanks a lot for calling
apologize to those of you calling in
it's hard for us to deal with individual
cases beyond the fact that you give out
and i don't mean to be abrupt or cut you
off and i'm sure
a lot of you don't get everything out
that you want to say but there are a lot
of people in line to talk this is some
video
from some of the shops in hanoi
and we asked permission of that
gentleman right there if we could uh
shoot
call that sweep
but shooting tape is what we're shooting
and he was very cooperative and this is
just a
street lined with little shops of curios
and souvenirs and
some produce vegetables tucson arizona
thanks for waiting
yes sir
i know you've got to be fair and have
all kinds of different guests on there
but your last guest
sounded more like a political uh push
for uh mr bush concerning he brought up
uh
the other candidate uh about his vietnam
deal and uh usually he should have just
stuck to his agent orange stuff that
supposedly he knows so much
people are with rash's skin falling off
for them the cancer in the the vets uh
yet they can't tell me what's causing
mine uh
it's something that two doctors have
classified toxic but like one of your
gentlemen that you had on the phone said
the va doctors
are controlled they will not put that
down because they will be reprimanded
where uh where were you in vietnam and
when uh hoi an 69 and 70. and i got to
meet mr zumwalt's son he was pbr
and i was in the marine corps we ran the
river patrols
he went up to genoa island and
he had come up from the south and where
they got an officer and a gentleman this
man was an officer and a gentleman thank
you for calling sir louisville kentucky
are next yes what's on your mind yeah i
was calling i've been listening to your
program and i was in vietnam i was over
there from 68 to 72
and i was just listening to some of your
people in the comments that we're making
and it just makes me real upset to hear
people uh you know
uh say this and that happened and
everything like that the government
wants to cover up everything they never
tell the truth about anything who
doesn't the government the government
yeah we went to vietnam you know it was
supposed to be for communism all that uh
the american people uh you know when
they send somebody in there they should
support them and what happens uh to the
veteran when he gets back nobody
supports anybody thank you sir lebanon
missouri you're next okay you're on the
air
okay want me to talk now you bet sir
okay uh i was in vietnam
you know 69 and 70.
and i came back
and i had a baby
and uh
the baby died and they didn't know what
it was from
they said it was script death
and uh
i
[Music]
been having a skin problem
you know
i've been to the va about
seven eight times
and they don't know the problem of the
of the skin
they always tell me is this and this
that
where were you stationed in vietnam oh i
was stationed in a full bat
and was there any agent orange sprayed
in that area
i believe so
and have you discussed the with the va
whether or not they
think it's uh
agent orange connected
well they they say they don't know and i
had a test
uh
last year
in uh
va hospital in latin world
and they said that uh
they don't
they they said it's not connected with
uh agent orange all right sir thanks for
calling baltimore maryland go ahead
please yes um
i'm a vietnam veteran and
i wanted to make several comments
uh one was regarding mr reed irvine he
apparently wasn't familiar with naval
operations in vietnam
because he referred to riverine boats as
being
offshore ships
they were as close to defoliant as
anybody as a matter of fact we were
sprayed several times
um
and another thing i would like to thank
admiral zumwalt for using defoliant
he
saved a lot more of my friends than were
lost
through agent orange
thank you for calling sir pismo beach
california you're next
yeah uh i have a comment to make i i
hear a lot of the aftermath of the
vietnam war
and uh
adrian orange but
unfortunately i don't hear a lot about
the reason for the war in the first
place
i have a comment to make that uh
before the vietnam war got started china
was in a five-year
program to industrialize unfortunately
their food ratio
is about one to one
south vietnam
in the delta area there's enough rice to
beat all of china
that war was spot over rice if if
anybody doubts that
when the war was over
when cam when vietnam invaded cambodia
they invaded cambodia because the
cambodians the coma rouge were supported
by red china and they were working in
cambodians to death moving that rice to
uh into
china the soviets didn't want that
neither did the united states
[Music]
subsequently
the russians
went in with the vietnamese and stopped
that rice flow
that part of the reason for the war in
vietnam has never been told
all right sir thanks
for your
call and your input
this gentleman right here will be with
us in about an hour and five minutes
tran van gaal or ka tran van depending
on uh the the magazine prints it one way
and we get it another we'll ask him when
he get here and he gets here exactly
what his last name is parade magazine
from august 23rd jim webb former
secretary of the navy will be with us on
thursday
to talk about the vietnam war thursday
is devoted to more to the economics
of that part of the world elizabeth
county kentucky you're next thank you
what's on your mind
uh
i just want to make a comment on
mr with a comment that mr irvine made
about admiral zimwalt's son
and that after all he was based on
ships that weren't exposed to asian
orange
and i've quite admired admiral zimbank
for a long time and read a lot of his
stuff and listened to him on television
and his description indicates that his
son was
frequently exposed to agent orange as he
went up and down in the brown river
or brown water patrol did you know
people involved in the war
yes
family
no family no
all of my family uh was in the second
world war what do you think of the trade
embargo should it continue with vietnam
you know after looking at your thing
about the hospital and everything
i think that that as some comments were
made i think we need to do like we did
after japan
and germany and
we need to have say like a mini marshall
plan that gets in and helps
as far as like the hospitals and things
like that
uh i was real i work in a facility that
is medically based
and i was real impressed with what they
had there as little as they had to do
with it and everything all right thanks
a lot for the call we've got about two
and a half hours to go on this day day
three of our vietnam revisited program
that was originally run over memorial
day
again this was a video from our trip to
vietnam back in april and many of you
asked us to repeat it those of you who
missed some of the program a lot of it
was overnight during the memorial day
weekend we'll be able to see it either
today
thursday or friday wilmington north
carolina go ahead please yes mr lam aye
let me turn this down
i'm the mother of a veteran of 67 68 in
vietnam he's in the artillery
he uh
they they clear the ground you know
defoliate and scoop it out and that's
where the artillery is
so i know he was exposed and then on
convoys
there were defoliated areas that they
went through all the time and they were
actually sprayed with it he sent home
color pictures so we've seen the orange
ground yeah and i just don't have any
doubt that these boys were exposed many
of them how about your son now my son
has uh just lost a job they called it
environmental illness but it's
respiratory uh disturbances and he's
covered with breaking out and
you know just
fatigue and that sort of thing and now
his 12 year old son has developed a
biochemical brain disorder
and we're very uh you just don't ever
get over this hurt from vietnam
i think it will be with me until i go
and i wonder how much longer for all
these fellas thanks a lot for calling
appreciate it um
we've got uh what we're showing there's
some video of
the metropol hotel which is the
new it's a it's an old hotel that was
refurbished and just opened up uh when
we were there we were our group did not
stay in this hotel we stayed at the army
guest house uh but this is the only
hotel in the city that could be given
any kind of a star rating the rest are
this is 40 owned by the french and it's
a joint venture with the vietnamese and
we go to columbia maryland for our next
call go ahead please good afternoon i
spent 1967 as a navy corpsman with the
marines and i-corps yes sir um that's up
north right okay
live in ang et cetera
my son has been diagnosed with a genetic
disorder
it's called skeletal dysplasia
it's a form of skeletal dysplasia
the doctors don't seem to be able to
pinpoint why this would occur there's
nothing in my or my wife's background
that would indicate anything like this
we have two other
quite normal children this disorder
means that my son's
the ball and socket the ball is not
forming into the socket
in all his joints it's doubtful he'll
grow to be much more than four and a
half feet tall now do you directly
connect that with dioxin well
there's nothing else
the doctors indicated there's nothing
else they they they can't explain
why this has occurred apparently this is
the sixth
diagnosed case in the united states so
it's not something that happens often
it also is apparently i'm the first
person that was exposed to agent orange
that had a child
with this disorder where are you getting
your medical uh treatment for your son
uh children's hospital washington you
have to pay that for that yourself
well yeah through through our insurance
but in other words the veterans
hospitals don't take care of this for
you uh how long are you in the service i
was in four years
no no so the veteran
the the va uh still
doesn't want to admit i don't believe
these these problems exist and something
like this they really don't want to talk
about it
we can't prove that this is specifically
related to agent orange uh
so therefore it's not all right thanks a
lot for letting us know about it coming
up in about uh
12-13 minutes we'll take you to the
prosthetic center via videotape in
saigon this is a center where people
that have missing limbs
vietnamese can go and for nothing get
on the spot within four hours brand new
limbs and the whole process will be
explained to you fred downs who lost the
lemon vietnam and is a
a veteran of the vietnam war now works
at the veterans administration will be
our guest for an hour or so after the uh
tour of the prosthetic center also tran
vanca who has started
his own uh
assistance program in kanto which is
down south of saigon will also be with
us to tell us how that works he came
over here came over as a matter of fact
and started out as a janitor in
springfield virginia in a mall there and
today owns uh taco amigo restaurants and
has bee has done quite well according to
the article in parade fremont california
go ahead please
hello hi you're on the air
uh you're a brand yes i am and please
turn down your television hiya brian hi
okay i i would like thanks to japan
talking about vietnamese i have a uh
some concerns about lake tobacco and
vietnam
the first thing
uh
i don't think
okay we live in muggle right now until
vietnamese woman
they
respond about po p-o-w-m-i-a
for
america
and the second thing
and i don't think human rights
have a human right under vietnam
when did you come here
uh
1981. how did you get here oh i skipped
my boat
and why did you come
oh because in my life okay uh at the
i'm a 37 year old
i'm just for the army about one year
and uh
and you left by boat from where saigon
river yeah
how long did it take you to get here and
where did you stop first oh i buy uh
three or four days and i stopped by
indonesia
and in the gallon
refugee camp
and i lived there about six months and
arrived on new york
and uh
1981. do you have family here or were
they here already oh i escaped by
myself okay but my family
they come here under the program for so
because my father he a
major of understanding vietnam and he go
to rebel
education camp for about six years
re-education camp in vietnam yeah after
the war was over yes and he is here with
you now
yes
what do you do for a living
oh right now he already oh he got a sick
he about 64 65 years old what do you do
for a living
right now i'm working for a
semi-conductor company
thanks thanks a lot for calling and
sharing your story with us on the screen
now is the old
former u.s consulate in hanoi
this is the building that they showed us
while we were in hanoi they suggested
that if there ever
was renewed relations between our
countries that this might again be the
the embassy
and there are
a lot of embassies in this particular
area of vietnam
did although they told us what was in
there now but it's
obviously occupied
the uh
consulate in vietnam hanoi
for the united states uh we have not had
relations with that part of um
vietnam the north since 1954. we go next
to fairfax virginia go ahead please okay
uh brian uh your comp you're looking for
comments on
visiting vietnam revisiting vietnam yeah
sure uh i'm an ex-marine and vietnam
veteran i was in the vietnam when i was
18. i was a machine gunner
where uh
south of danang hill 55 hill 270 place
called dodge city by slang
and i think it's interesting that
they're doing it because for me brian uh
when i look back and i donated over 5000
slides to the marine corps archives
i look back at pictures and photos and
movies of vietnam now it doesn't seem
like it ever happened
have you been back no no no no
any desire to go back yes i have a uh i
guess a uh a vicarious curiosity you
know uh just wanting to see it's like
going back after an automobile accident
or something wanting to look but i'm one
of the fortunate few uh brian i was able
to uh seek out counseling
and i've had the same counselor for
almost 20 years since i came back from
vietnam
and what concerns me today
is primarily the education or lack of
education of the typical vietnam veteran
they don't know how to get help
there are some very very angry people
walking the streets very dangerous
people walking the street what do you
suggest to him
i wouldn't know where to begin to tell
you except that i know i sought help
from the veterans administration and and
it took almost 15 years for them to
finally come about and give me some help
what are you doing now
what do i do for a living yeah i'm a
real estate appraiser are you still
angry
yes uh part of me is working
i'm working through that uh the desert
storm hip hip hurrah that these boys
were heroes and the big parade when you
know when we got off a plane from
vietnam we had to hit the shuffles down
to the other end because of crowds
throwing rocks and beer bottles
where'd you come back to this country in
what city oh let's see uh andrews air
force base
all right thanks for the call uh we've
got some video to show you as we take a
call from alexander virginia of what's
called a hero's cemetery this is right
outside of hanoi
a cemetery obviously to uh what the
folks that live up in that area consider
heroes from the war and we go and this
was written about in fred downs's book
uh
no longer enemies not yet friends is the
title of his book and he'll be with us
in about an hour alexandra virginia
you're next
yes brian enjoy your program very much
thank you sir
i'm a vietnam veteran of having been
there twice
i find it very
amazing that doctors are unwilling to
pinpoint uh i've had
hodgkin's disease
since my exposure
uh
i have asked numerous medical doctors in
in the navy and uh
why they always caveat
the agent orange
uh lymphoma less hot skins i've never
been able to get a reasonable answer
from any medical doctor you're
suggesting that if you have lymphoma
they
will say that that that could have been
caused by agent orange but hodgkin's not
that's that's my
determination from discussions however
none of them have been able to really
look me in the eye and say that we can't
really distinguish between the two and i
think that information should be passed
to other people
thanks san francisco you're next
yeah
my name is robert i'm a vietnam veteran
i'm service connected for agent orange
i was uh with the first emperor
tradition lerp team
and when i was dropped into the jungle
with my team
everyone in my team was broken out with
big and infections i mean just
post-build infections
what year excuse me what year
69-70 and have you been proven to have
uh disability as a result of agent
orange now service connected part
and
where did you get that through the
veterans hospitals right i went into the
hospital for ptsd
which is
post-traumatic stress disorder
and they found the agent orange
connection right
and they put it on my uh
my purple card
now
the government is is not taking care of
their duty on this
i
when they say this doesn't happen you
should i can't believe the infection
that these men had and now i've got them
that i think i'm service connected being
a medic i had everything documented at
the time of my infections what is your
life like now what do you do you work no
i'm i'm disabled you're totally disabled
yes you mind telling us what kind of
what kind of benefits do you get from
the government because of your
disability what i mean what's life like
um
my infections caused me a lot of
problems like now i've got them all over
my body i don't let them get out of hand
if they start coming on
i have to open them up and clean them
out
other than acknowledging it there's been
no assistance you get you get medical
care for this yes i when i understand if
you're service connect for agent orange
you have free lifetime medical benefits
what kind of uh stipend do you get from
the government every month how much i
get my 50 for post-traumatic stress
disorder and that comes to right around
five hundred dollars
and that's what do you live on that
i plus i get my social security part and
how much is that oh about 650 a month so
you're talking about living you pay tax
on any of that no
so you've got what about eleven twelve
hundred dollars a month to live about 11
38 to be exact
can you make it
i
yeah it's i don't live well but i live
and you live in the city of san
francisco yes and that makes it even
harder but i've learned that of the
places that i have lived san francisco
and this surrounding surrounding area
has the best medical treatment for the
vets that i have seen all right sir
thanks a lot for your story we go for
our final call for this segment as we
look at um
actually that's a statue of the only
statue that i've seen in either eastern
europe or in moscow
of
lenin and it was found
the only place in any communist country
at least a communist country of recent
origin
was in the city of that's the paul du
may bridge by the way in the background
the long bend bridge it's also called
but the statue there was right across
from the army museum of of lenin in
hanoi
last call for this second no i guess
we're going to take two more
we go to toms river new jersey go ahead
please
yes sir i'm a vietnam veteran
i was uh in the shaw valley and i'd like
to make a comment to mr irvine
who stated that they were only spraying
the aged orange on the enemy
well i'll tell you
i'd like to know where he got his
glasses down because there's been times
and places in that jungle where it's
been so dark
that in the middle of the day you
thought it was midnight sprayed and you
say it was you were sprayed during the
war
yes sir i was you'd get sprayed while
you were sleeping while you were eating
and while you were walking and you were
in the ashaw valley
yes sir i worked all the way from the
shaw valley up to hill 7 59 and what
year were you there i was there from 70
to 73.
all right sir thanks a lot for the call
last call for this segment albany new
york go ahead please uh yes brian thank
you very much i was disappointed you
didn't have somebody there to rebut read
irvine uh generally right 99 percent of
the time except on dioxin and agent
orange well we had a whole bunch of time
spent on it for people who thought it
was connected then that's the reason why
uh mr irvine was here to have a chance
to give the other side i missed the uh
most of the conversation with uh admiral
zumwalt and dr schechter i don't know if
they mentioned uh kate jenkins from the
environmental protection agency i don't
remember blower on agent orange i wish
you would bring her to your program and
let her discuss her knowledge of agent
orange she has forced the environmental
protection agency to initiate a criminal
investigation against monsanto chemical
company for falsifying scientific
documents on agent orange one more point
uh dr
reid irvine liked to mention
the ranch hand study uh
september 9 1988 tom daschle in the in
the senate received a letter from
a scientist he was a scientist who
prepared the final report on ranch hand
herbicide operations in southeast asia
july 1971
and while assigned to the department of
life sciences usa after completing his
work in vietnam uh one extract from his
letter he says here when we military
scientists initiated the herbicide
program in the 1960s we were aware of
the potential for damage due to dioxin
contamination and the herbicide we were
even aware that the military formulation
had a higher dioxin concentration than
the civilian version due to the lower
cost and speed of manufacturer however
because the material was to be used on
the enemy none of us were overly
concerned we never considered a scenario
in which our own personnel would become
contaminated with the herbicide all
right sir thanks a lot for the call and
thanks for uh your suggestion on getting
a guest for a future program on this
issue by the way we understand and our
information is not precise it's hard to
get it uh but the election
that was held in july they had an
election after we were there the
national assembly there were 400 roughly
430 members of the assembly
they supposedly were elected two-thirds
new members there was an attempt on the
part of the party most of them almost
all of them were party members to elect
people with college education because
they wanted a higher
education level for their assembly that
supposedly now two-thirds of the
assembly are college graduates
noba tong who you'll see tomorrow on
this network and interview with her
and she's been schooled here in the
united states
lost she ran again and lost her election
she was one of the few independent
members
allegedly independent in uh in vietnam
and jack owen who you'll also see in an
interview did not run again we said the
other day that he had run but he decided
for one reason or another not to run
fred downs and tran van gaal will be our
guest in about 45 minutes
next up back to saigon via videotape
this was taped in may i'm sorry april on
our trip there
we spent uh
excuse me an afternoon
at a prosthetic
uh center that was created
for the purpose of providing limbs
for people who
were injured during the war and we'll go
to that now
uh
[Music]
doctor can you explain to us um what you
do here at this institute
um
[Music]
prosthetic
institute is located in on the other
district and this is only center process
process center
this center is outcome of the
cooperation between the prosthetic
center in seattle and
the prosthetic institute in hanoi
[Music]
so the prosthetic institute in seattle
provided all of equipment here
and the work here is
what is being carried out
about for two years
it was built up during 1991 and 1992
who's eligible
to come to this center and be treated
for a prosthetic
arm or leg
among them maybe the soldiers or the
ordinary people
who suffer from handicapped men so it
doesn't have to be someone who fought in
the war no
not
in fact they no need for they are free
of charge here so if i
am in need of a prosthetic do i just
come to the
center here and tell them that i want an
arm or a leg and how long does it take
to get one uh
[Music]
[Music]
our institute our center is research
center
and we cooperated with the seattle the
sen the institute in seattle in doing
the uh the legs you know
not not up to the hip
right
and as for the arms we
have not
created any
arms
could we just let could we see how it
works here i mean where the
the the actual room where it's uh
people are examples
invited
how many people work here
or
something like
about six or seven
trial center experimental
and how many people do you treat a month
[Music]
on average we produce about 100 and
200 left artificial legs
[Music]
we just
[Music]
this cargo is
enough for making uh 500 left
we reset this from seattle
underneath
[Music]
who is chairman of the seattle
uh prosthetic
center
he also visited our center and took part
in
inaugural
functions here
as i told you that our center is
research center and
this is a
experimentation
phrase
and we also take advantage of the
technology advanced technology of the
seattle uh center
seattle
what is different today in in providing
a prosthesis than it would be say a
couple of years ago
uh
[Music]
so
over the past years we the center
prosthetic centers throughout the
country
will work under the traditional
techniques
and this is the only the unique center
which use the new advanced technology
technique
using the system of backhand
this
is over here on this board
what are we looking at this is a
computer designer
here computer design and computer
manufacture
and this is a
very modern
machine producing circuit
how many of the 150 or 200
prosthetics that you treat every month
[Music]
[Music]
so we make no difference between the
soldiers and the people
and we produce 100 to 120 not 200. no i
understand but how many of those are
done
the soldiers occupied 60
of the
clients and if this center wasn't here
they would not be able to get a
prosthetic
[Music]
over the 15 past years we have already
our centers producing artificial limbs
with the assistant from abroad
and even in the south we also got
already the assistant from the usa
how long does it take from the moment
someone comes here
until they leave in order to have a
prosthetic
ready to wear um
[Music]
so it takes four hours
to to get an artificial limb if
artificial limb if client come here at
eight o'clock in the morning and at 12
12 o'clock
in the midday they can get out with the
artificial limb could we see someone
yeah okay
like
i tell the people to come back to their
home and come here in four days but if
in fact
it will take for four hours
and this is a
experimentation
center so we have to go to go to
different provinces
to choose people
so all the material in here has been
shipped from seattle
center uh worship from seattle but then
we try to make uh this one by by
ourselves
to save money to save uh
transportation fees
and is the seattle research institute
supplying uh money for this project
[Music]
they helped us they provided with
us with equipment and
artificial limbs is there any way of
knowing how much in a year's time it
costs to
fit 2 000 limbs which is you know
roughly an idea of how many you do in a
year how much does that all cost
um
during the past year the only past year
1991
we have
we produced 1 000 artificial limbs and
each
costs
ranging
from 180 to
200 us dollars
let me introduce to you the
this is the the
part of the legs of the the soldiers the
people below
below the knee
uh
can you give us
steps like this
first
we
[Music]
[Music]
the
um
sorry
just a moment
just a moment please
[Music]
what are we actually looking at there
the socket the socket yeah that is that
the actual prosthesis
sorry is that the actual prosthesis is
that what's used
yeah maybe
yeah
look it will go down from this one
so
over there
is that is this machine from seattle
it was shipped from seattle but produced
in england
ship from the company abt atv
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Applause]
to the the lack of the patience
this is a major step in investing
process
and then we have to assemble other
details in together
let's go
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
legitimate
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]
how often does the power go off
[Music]
generally speaking it depends on the
power
plant
it depends on the source
does it happen the time is not fixed the
time
when the electricity go up does it cause
a problem though when you're trying to
make these prosthesis
[Music]
we have
our own
[Music]
generator is on the way to be uh
re-charged
[Music]
[Music]
is this gentleman being
fitted for a new one
um
this morning yeah
how did this gentleman lose his lower
which
uh
m
[Music]
originally
and when will you when was he first
treated for a prosthetic you know after
that uh
um
i i was getting treatment in many uh
hospitals in vietnam
since 1964.
how does how does he feel go ahead i'm
sorry and this this centers
belong to the ministry of labor social
affairs and invalids of war
how does he feel about having a
prosthesis that was partially paid for
by american support
so we suffer
a lot during the war and the world
caused by americans and i think that and
we suffer from the war and
we are a victim of the war
the one year
so i think that we have to uh resolve
the aftermath the consequences of the
war
and uh up to now so far we uh we have
done uh
very few were few things
uh in in the resolving of the aftermath
of the war
and i think that the
the american people also during the war
woke up and to
another a letter and then to criticize
the war
is he are you still angry with americans
from uh
this situation that that came to you
during the war
um
among the american people a lot of
people are very good only one
a very small group
of people uh wanted to wage a war
against vietnam at that time
and i think that
we have to resolve the consequences of
the war uh in the humanitarian spirit
how does this feel this is a new leg
does it feel better than the one that he
just had before this today
is
foreign
foreign
over the past years in the factory
uh
helped
will build with the help from germany
and
the artificial socket was made from the
aluminium
and from the wooden wood not from the
black plastic not not plastic socket
so
it is different from from
uh from
previous
artificial limbs
thank you very much and could we ask you
your name uh
and how old are you and where do you
live now
i am now
66 years old and i live i am living now
in hanoi thank you very much
i
was informed that the center was
held by the seattle institute so i think
that through you i would like to thank
american people who
helped the to build this
process hypothesis center
in the human
humanitarian aid
and
where is this gentleman from
uh
the chairman yesterday
yeah i'm from the north how did this
happen to you
uh
[Music]
just by accident
how long ago
uh
uh
where is he from originally
from the north from the north from
what's different about this from the
last leg that he had
[Music]
in terms of beautiful beauty
and in terms of uh
[Music]
fitness
the first
that's the first one yeah it's a lot
heavier
the german made
left artificial left are heavier much
heavier than this
how long did you have this leg the other
one
this is produced here
in this center
but how long did he wear that
[Music]
half a half a year
[Music]
uh
[Music]
good night
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
easy
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
where did you uh use lose your leg
in laos
in
1972 in what kind of a battle
attention
kingdom
bomb
battle
metal battle against whom uh
but the plan
and how do you feel about your new leg
uh
very good
where do you live now
whatever
[Music]
district
in osgood of hanoi and what do you do
what's your work
so i'm
engaging in
in acupuncture
and
give the actual people to give them
chinese medicines
did you ever fight in the war against
americans
like
at the time our task is
against the
bandits
thailand also and americans
how do you feel then about this part of
this prosthesis being paid for by
americans
[Music]
and
consequences of the war and
i i would like i am very glad and i
would like to thank american people and
their charity
do you think
fighting in the war was worth what
happened afterwards are you happy with
the way the word came out
of
[Music]
after the war the life
of the vietnamese people is very
difficult in terms of uh
economic difficulties
and i and it's more difficult for the
crippled the the handicapped people
and i have to
and in terms of support the children and
in terms of
being employed
could i ask you what your rank was when
you got out of the military and how old
you are today
foreign
um
i i was at the time 30 years old
yeah i was
non-commissioned
at the time
and we get this gentleman's name
with
n-g-y-e-n
h-u-y
k-y
when
we
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
where are you from
[Music]
i came from the the village uh 25 kilo
kilometers from hanoi
and where were you during the war
as other vietnamese people i took part
in army and then i was transferred to
work
in one of the hospitals
were you
a doctor during the war
i used to be a
worker and then engineer and then
transferred to to deal with the
prosthesis
work
where did you get your medical degree
um
[Music]
trained uh
in
in east germany for two years and then
uh
i
had i worked in vietnam for 10 years and
then i
i went to west germany also for one year
what year was west germany
1985.
and did you lose
many friends or family in the war
yourself
[Music]
and all of them took part in army and
one
died
and the second brother
was
wounded on hand
and
the brother
is technician in the automobile
industry have you been to the united
states
[Music]
[Music]
in december 1989
i went to the united states america with
other people to
receive
the
aid from settle center
how do you feel
after all these years working with
americans in this area is it at all
difficult
they are very friendly americans
are very friendly and very very good i
it's very easy to work with them
is there any anger left in your feelings
about since the war
[Music]
so i'm aware of the changes of the
situation very quickly
you recognize the
situation
very quickly so i think that the
reconciliation between the two countries
is
necessary thank you
fred downs this is recorded back in
april you joined us over memorial day
after a long trip back from vietnam your
10th
anything happened to this prosthetic
center since we were there in april well
um the one in hanoi yeah they're
continuing to manufacture limbs
the
group that's doing that they considered
a research project really out of seattle
and so they're making changes as they go
along we have
reviewed and made some suggestions as to
how they can improve that product in our
trip from april so
last report it's
churning out limbs have you been there
to vietnam since may when we talked no
not since may
can you give us an update you're still
with the veterans administration oh
that's correct i'm uh
i'm the uh director of prosecutor aid
service for the veterans administration
and i think that's that's crucial to why
general vessey chose me for this mission
uh i've been the director for 12 years
and are you still with the vessel
commission or the vet yes i'm still part
of the vesey humanitarian team
and um general vessey was general john
vessey was
chief of staff of
well actually did i say that right
under reagan he was
chairman of the joint chiefs of staff
at the pentagon and so that was the end
of a long career that started out as an
enlisted man in world war ii so he's a
wonderful gentleman to work for and
you've been a part of this vesey is it
called a commission it's it's really
called the the the bessie vesey mission
i mean that's what we call it in the
short term his official title is
presidential emissary to vietnam on
pow-mia affairs still active that's
right and he was appointed to that by
reagan in 1987 and you're still involved
and i'm still involved as part of this
humanitarian
efforts can you update us
yes since may
i can we have um
as you uh as you know or may not know i
think it's important for the audience to
know last year when we made our first
trip for the usaid that was the first
time that u.s dollars
have been spent in vietnam since
the end of the war in 1975 a couple of
crucial points that need to make here is
that
there's been concern whether more money
was spent in the south or more money in
the north and of course we were very
sensitive to that the vietnamese wanted
money uh spent in the north but they
also recognized our concerns that we
wanted money spent in the south because
the south needed a lot of help
and so when we
proposed after that trip that 1.3
million dollars should be spent in
vietnam
i think uh it's important for people to
know that 275
000 of that went to the hanoi center
but the
1.005 million dollars went in the south
and that was it to da nang
quinai quinyan and the trang
as those centers and there was some
going to kanto but uh since that period
why
kanto has taken a different route
to do what
to provide prosthetic appliances and it
was designed to
to
give some
internal strength to the existing
prosthetic programs that were at these
particular areas and locations
and also to see where more need was
going to come in the future so that was
the first money that went into vietnam
that were u.s dollars and that's
separate from non-governmental
organizations or
private groups that have been going in
as a result of the private of the vessey
mission now
since then
approximately another million dollars is
going to be
spent in vietnam by usaid and of course
all this is being
being funded and managed by usaid
through their
through their particular
offices overseas and through the
washington office here
and that million dollars is going to be
spent mostly in the rehabilitate
rehabilitation medicine areas
for instance reconstruction surgery
revision surgery for
limbs that need revision or
need to correct scarring as leading to
lots of pain and
enabling people not to be able to fit
prostate glands this all tied to people
who were injured during the war no no
it's uh people injured during the war
but uh but really any disabled today for
the audience that that has never seen
you before you have three books
no longer
enemies not yet friends the the title of
your latest book that's correct and
not to emphasize this or overemphasize
this but you have an artificial limb
that's right did you where did you lose
your arm it's an above l
above elbow amputation on my left side
and i lost it as an infantry officer in
vietnam
um near chulai uh in 1968
january 11th how long were you in the
army
i was in the army a total of uh three
years
a year and a half of it was uh spending
training a half year in combat and then
the rest of the time in the hospital and
how long have you been with the veterans
administration i've been with vendors
administration uh 19 years now we got
time to catch up you're a hoosier by
birth but we have another guest we want
to introduce this is parade magazine
from august to 23rd
and this gentleman here on the left
is ka van tran
and on the right is the navy secretary
former navy secretary jim webb
and uh cavantran is here with us in the
studio as you saw just a moment ago
why'd they do this
cover story on you
well
um it's part of the program that we have
ongoing in vietnam
in assistance a
mpt in south vietnam
past may
i
traveled with me with mr webb and his
companions
mike mccarvey who's uh the vietnam vet
we went there and we visited a different
prosthetic clinic
including one the one that we operated
out in kanto
and
since it came back
jim thought this
would be beneficial to the program by
taking it public
and
i'm grateful that
parent magazine
in the past several weeks as well as the
washington post
have run similar
article about the
operation that we have in vietnam let me
ask you a couple of questions uh they're
not they're little questions they're
important questions though you left
vietnam when
i left vietnam in the last day of uh
april 1975. that was the day that all
the americans left too
they they left before that i literally
um get out on the boat as a vietnamese
communist
uh occupying the other side of town
where did you get the boat there in the
saigon river harbor yeah and you went
where from saigon well from there
april 30th
the evening we
were pushed toward the international
water
and from there we were picked up by the
american navy uh seventh fleet
uh matter of fact we were picked up by
the u.s merchant marine ship out there
and took us to uh civic base
in the philippines philippines where
were you what were you doing in vietnam
before you left well i worked for
a contractor which had the
subcontract with the aid
until the
minutes that i left saigon
let me read a paragraph from jim webb's
article in
in the parade magazine
he found work as a janitor in virginia's
suburban springfield mall i'll say
that's right outside of washington here
then as the manager of a mexican
restaurant and later as a courier for
federal express
after a few years he took the plunge
into entrepreneurship today he lives in
a million dollar home dabbles in real
estate and owns four restaurants his own
chain called taco amigo is all that true
that's correct yeah how did you do that
well uh
it took a lot of energies and
disciplines
to
and for the most part with because the
drive of uh trying to forget about
vietnam uh basically and uh honestly
i haven't been through the difficult
time in the past and the
broke down the families and during the
war and
emotionally involved with you know
the tie the broken and everything else
i couldn't stop for any minutes to you
know because if i do uh
it's it's tremendous enduring to do so
so i kept on working
and uh by
hard laboring
somehow you know it pay off where are
your four taco amigos right here in
virginia
yes
right in the suburbs yeah it's uh
across the river from here
mexican food
mexican food how did you get interested
in mexican food
well
i started out as a cook as a
restaurant in the mall
for
from the beginning
i didn't know anything else to do you
know i worked with the
u.s marine
early on and then worked with the
aid
in vietnam as interpreter
translator and
get off the boat came over here i didn't
know what else to do they didn't need no
interpreter around here
so i took a job with the mall as the
janitor
i worked very hard so the mall
owner
recommended me to
work with the
restaurant in the mall whereas the pay
higher
so uh automatically i learned the trade
do you have a family
i'm married i have a couple kids do you
two know each other
yes where did you meet i mean have you
has your work taken you in connection
with
mr trans doing yes our work brought us
together uh i think call could
could explain how that occurred and uh
i'll let him start off
but actually right right before we went
on the air you mentioned just two
seconds before the cameras came on that
in your first book killing zone yes that
you wrote about an area where
yes i wrote about the fact that i was in
duck foe in that area around duck foe
and when colin and i first met why um we
discovered uh we we talked about that uh
my time in vietnam and i mentioned duck
foe and then he said that he was from uh
from an area around duckville also so uh
it's
it's uh wonderful sometimes how
events bring us together at different
periods of our lives
and what is you're doing i mean the
article is all about uh some things that
you're doing over in kento which is what
is it a four hour drive from saigon
south yeah
i must back up a little bit to fill you
in what are we doing in and how i get
there and what's going on there now
i left vietnam in 1975
and
haven't been back there until 15 years
later in 1990 november 1990
what is thought to be
a visit of my father who were very sick
at the time
he's ada
it turned out to be a
shocking experience for me
to see
the deteriorating
conditions and the poverty level of
vietnam
at the time
so
instead of vocationing i
quickly returned to the u.s and trying
to
talk it all with my friends here
american and vietnamese american in
the community
um to get some help to vietnam to to do
to the people that
we left behind
especially the one that
were wounded during the war
the one that we left behind got some
pictures here i'll hold them up for the
camera so we can see some of the people
you're talking about these people
have been largely
ignored and neglected by the society
since the war stopped
they nothing that
assisted in the area of
frustrated anything to these people at
all
there is program going on in the north
and central vietnam and in saigon but
especially in canter
very not much going on at all in terms
of
humanitarian assistance to the
individual amputee
so
we organize and form a non-profit
organization called vietnam assistant
for the handicap
primarily we wanted to
give them
artificial limbs
and medical supply
through the clinic encounter
and it's been going on since
1991.
how much money have you raised
we generates
a few
through a few
receptions fundraising it's not much
an organization here in town
the
disabled american veterans give us a
30 000 cash grant
christopher reynolds in new york
foundation in new york give us five
thousand dollars
and uh donation coming in from the
vietnamese american
community individual businessman
it's not much but this money go a long
way in vietnam when you
when you see
around 20 30 per limbs can put
an amputee back on his own feet
getting his
own
you know freedom going about doing work
be more productive so it was very
meaningful
what would what would it cost in
american dollars to get a limb
oh an american limb for a leg for
instance can for below knee would be
it could be uh let's say around four
thousand dollars three thousand four
thousand dollars depending upon the type
and quality of the uh
componentry would it be the same quality
of lamb that mr trans talking about
costing 20 in vietnam no it's not the
same type of limb not this it's just
different components different materials
they use mostly at kanto they use the
products that are native to that area
how does what you're doing at the
veterans administration i mean with
investing okay group fit in with what mr
tran has done well this is i think uh
you know what has occurred over the
years since 87 when we returned in 87
it was the recommendation by our by the
vessel group was to
allow non-governmental organizations to
go into vietnam to start to provide uh
prosthetic aid
and at first there were only a handful
three or four five
non-governmental organizations that
decided to do that
some of them were world vision the
quakers
the the friends
and
over the period of years since 87 more
and more groups became involved
small groups groups of vietnam veterans
and
there was a generating excitement as
each year passed more and more people
started going in
then
when caltron
wanted to meet with me
i was excited about it because the first
time
that we would have a vietnamese group
who wanted to go back to vietnam
and so
when he arranged to meet with me why
we started exchanging ideas
but
katran and his group are one of many
groups that have been going in as a
result of the us government's decision
back in 87 to allow these groups to
start going into vietnam in spite of the
restrictions against vietnam the trading
with the enemies act and and the embargo
and other
concerns at that time on a personal
level uh we understand from reading the
article that um
you send mixed signals supposedly both
to the communists in vietnam and to your
friends back here where they think
you're too close to the communists
and the people back there think that
you're
uh up too close to the americans is that
a problem for you
um
yes and no
well this is going to be a a
an ongoing
thing that they do on both sides
and
our objective and our goals are clear
i've been involved in this
out of my heart from my heart i have
compassion
i drop everything here you know owning
feels restaurants very very demanding
work
and take on the job at this magnitude
you have to really totally devote to it
in order to get it going
the needs in vietnam in terms of
humanitarians is tremendous
we go above and beyond the ordinary i
would say political and of that race
they're going to be there criticize and
talk behind you know but
is it clear that we're not going to
involve in
politics
during the first meeting with high
officer from hanoi
in 1991 in august 1991
i've been very upfront with them
on this issue
we're here to help
we want to reach back to the people that
we
left behind
we don't mind to go on
out and help
even nba amputee
or the civilians
and we've been
so far very cooperative at least from
the high level
government in vietnam
among our community that some people
would still you know take the attitude
of
skepticism about this and that but it's
becoming
ever so minority and
privately they expressed that you know
all supporting this especially since the
articles uh
even in vietnam we have um
the even the saigon time the only
english
language
newspaper over there as well at the
communist office or
newspaper i've been published article
about these programs
supporting us
how many trips have you made
so far
i made four trips
when was the last time you were there in
may you want to say something i wanted
to say that uh
you know cars oppressed uh me and the
other members of uh
the group usaid group that
and his efforts you know he's not
he's being very modest
he's had a tough road to hoe and the
vietnamese over in vietnam
they looked at him with a great deal of
uh
of suspicion at first and still do i
think
but uh you know the thing about kai's is
i've seen you talking to lots of people
in this community he's got a mission he
keeps plugging away at it and it really
comes from the heart and that's the
sense that you get and
and that
he's not given up in spite of some
adversity and he's starting i think to
get his point his message across
and uh
the fact that he is
you know going back to his country
helping his people i think has a
tremendous amount of uh of spirit and
appeal to it and and i just watched him
overcome these obstacles and he just
keeps on going he's just not the kind of
guy's going to get beat down i know why
he went from being a janitor to owning
the restaurant now
we are has your business hurt at all
during this time
uh that's the uh point that where i
always concerned you know especially you
know i have to go overseas and and left
the business for ongoing restaurant with
nobody to tend for
we have three and five-year-old kids and
my wife have to take care of them
but
money
and i have set up the priority
and the priority for me is not money
it's no longer money
or my own business or my own success
here is meaningful i
somewhat i thought this is the
call from god that i need to answer
and it's a mandate that
like
a couple weeks from now i've been in
vietnam and 300 amputees will be waiting
for me to get limbs
we work our deal with um
the management of counter center
whereas they produce the limbs they get
the measurement then they wait for us to
come back and and then
be on site to fit the amputee directly
so it's one of the tasks that we're
trying to overcome and for 300 limbs
with the vietnamese style technology i
would say take a couple weeks to
accomplish
it's very demanding work it's very much
involved but
uh on a personal level uh we have i have
to take a beating you need money
absolutely yeah we need a lot of help we
need a lot of help let me uh let me show
you uh a letter here and it's it it's
it's very well
saying what uh i'm trying to do
let me hold it up here so we can uh
these are a couple by the way this is
the this is the letter comment came from
a
measure who the assistant
uh district chief in look for where you
lost your arm
his letter dated
the 6th the july is 1992
his double amputee
he got wounded and blown up by a mine in
the battle in duke fall
back in 1972
after the war
he had to go to the re-education camp
three months three year and three months
even with his
severe
handicap
after release from the re-education camp
he lost his home he lost his elded
daughter his brother his father
half of his family vanished during the
war
and now with the qualification rubber
stem from the local government certified
that he's
wanted to port
poverty and handicap certification is
what he say
so he wrote to different organizations
humanitarian yeah that's a certification
it's robert stand by the vietnamese
local authority that he's the poorest
guy in town
so he can
reach out to us in different
organizations for help
by the way i will go back and give him a
wheelchair uh a couple weeks from now
that what he need
let me interrupt and tell our audience
that we're gonna go to phones in five
minutes our two guests will be with us
for another 35 minutes this is all part
of vietnam revisited fred downs has been
with us several times since all this
started on book notes
can you remember when we did the book
notes last year i guess i think it was
the beginning of this year was it began
this year i think so losing track of
time you've been here i know this is the
fourth trip
keeping a thread through this thing i
want to ask fred downs a couple of
questions and we're going to show you
some video tape of a meeting last week
in northern virginia in that uh
virginia that mr tron had with some
folks out here
you like he likes to be called car which
is his first name
ka
that's right yeah
and people call your car yes but not mr
carl no mr tran all right uh
what's can you bring us up to date at
all on on the mia pow question from your
perspective
the new um
i will mention that uh you know when
generals were when the assistant
secretary solomon was there earlier this
year and as part of that group there
were five things that came out of that
that the american government and the
vietnamese government agreed to that uh
really signified one of the biggest
steps we've made so far
and those five steps uh quickly read
them out was continuing the
trilateral efforts to resolve border
issues and what that meant was for those
individuals who are missing around the
borders of cambodia laos and vietnam why
you just can't go from one country to
the other and so they were going to work
together with other those countries to
to facilitate going into those areas
increase access to the records the
archives and the museums in vietnam
also three um
try to help implement a live siting
mechanism or what they call no notice in
other words would just show up or they
would show up and show the vietnamese an
area where they want to go where they
get on the helicopter and then tell the
vietnamese this is the area we want to
go to
renewing unilateral efforts to
to find and return remains
and the fifth was to implement a plan of
extended joint operations over the next
two years in other words our two teams
the american teams the vietnamese teams
to work
more of those teams to work in more
areas within vietnam
general tom needham is in charge of that
he's based out of hawaii and they're in
our basin
for the we have uh colonel donovan
who is stationed in hanoi with the the
other members of the team in vietnam and
and so
they are
all five of those areas are having
various degrees of success moving
forward generally you can say that it's
uh it's been positive um some i think we
would like to see quicker progress in
certain areas for sure
but um uh that's where we are today and
they just uh the remains keep coming
back and uh
there's some question about uh how fast
we can identify them but also is a
question of you know sometimes you get a
big pile of
just a pile of jungle and dirt and
different bones and pieces and it has to
be sorted out it takes a long time so
there's a lot more yet to be done fred
downs has a book no no longer enemies
not yet friends it's still in the
bookstores he'll be with us for a few
more minutes here until the bottom of
the hour as will
tran van ka kavantran
in if in vietnamese it's
tran van ka in america it's cave and
tran because
here's some of that videotape of this
meeting last week
that
mr tran had
so we're here tonight
to ask you for help
later on after dinner we encourage your
dialogue
we would like to to hear from you we
invite you to help
whatever you can do
fifty dollars would buy a limbs
would change a life
for a person in vietnam
fifty dollars would put
the man up on his both feet
go ahead job
regain his dignity
and be less of a burden for society
i don't know what else to say that
besides that we need help
tremendously needs in vietnam and the
encouraged thing
is
the the community being responded
got a lot of call and a lot of help we
totally concentrate in the humanitarian
area
we go above and beyond
what what should i say the ordinary
polit politic
we have nothing to do with it
and
you see the picture over there
the handicap
but
i can assure you that hundreds of them
like that
had commit suicide because they had no
hope
but now
those
remain alive
and they
fully
bless their hope
to your help
to united states
mr trent let me ask you while we watch
this meeting that you had first of all
what was the purpose of this evening
the evening was the
routine activity the vna designed to
if you will educated the public of what
our missions
really is in vietnam
uh
because the skepticism between this side
of
the country virtual to vietnamese side
we want to be constantly out in the open
our mission humanitarian we need help we
need
financial help we need material we need
support
sort like a recruiting i saw also
among the participants in that meeting
was lou puller who we have had here as a
guest on book notes yes and the
gentleman that was speaking earlier was
a general he was he's he was general
when van gaal he's also a chairman of
the vietnamese prisoner political
prisoner organization here in
this country there's lou puller on the
screen right there let's listen just a
little bit
will never end for me
and kah has given me
an opportunity and an avenue
to channel some of my energy and some of
my good fortune
back into
the wonderful country
but there is a language of the heart
that these men
understand that i understand
and that anyone understands
who has experienced hardship
and so honored
that i can be a part of this effort
thank you all and god bless you
[Applause]
thank you
by the way the book that lou puller
wrote was called fortunate son uh what
is your relationship i know we invited
you too independently to this group i
know
that you're a government employee so
you've got some sensitivity that's right
i have to uh i want to clarify that uh
you know what i support caw and all the
the humanitarian people groups that are
going into vietnam
and
i don't want to i want the audience to
think that i'm here exclusively to
support kaa and him exclusively there
are lots of different groups going in
and part of our job in the destination
is to encourage meet with all the groups
and
facilitate anything we can do to help
them succeed and so uh there's one need
to make that clear if people want to get
in touch with you
what's the number that they call or the
address that they use um
you can call vietnam assistant for the
handicap at 703-847-9582
when will somebody be at that number
it's the constantly monitor so the
numbers on the screen right now you can
see it there you can dial that number if
you're interested in being of any
assistance let's go to the telephones
here so i know people are anxious to
participate in this go ahead
philadelphia on the line
yes i was in vietnam from
1967 through 68 on in the
like uh from the
yeah from march to 67th and march 68th i
had a question about
agent orange
and what i'd like to know is
i was stationed in
kuchi and like k
and i'd like to know
if that area was extensively sprayed
with agent orange all right
i'm going to let you go i
this is not this program is not about
agent orange and we want to make sure
that we don't get that issue
dominating the program because we do not
have experts here on agent orange if uh
fred downs wants to make any comment at
all he's certainly willing to but i
don't want to folks out there who've
been listening to the discussion this
afternoon on asian orange start to call
about that issue or we won't get
anything accomplished during the next
hour do you know i just want to remind
him and the other listeners if there's
an asian orange problem uh the veterans
administration is maintaining a register
and we have a constant constant
sensitivity to that issue certainly now
please contact the local va medical
center and get on that list i don't want
to sound insensitive but these two
gentlemen do not have any expertise at
all on agent orange and that's not the
purpose of this hour tallahassee florida
go ahead please yes brian i've been
watching your show all day long today
and
i think that this is uh what these
gentlemen are doing are really showing
that the war is over whenever we start
doing kind acts like this
it uh
lets everyone know that the war is over
and the only way we're going to get a
true accounting is by
getting the diplomatic uh
ties back we might find out that our our
our own nation's hand weren't weren't as
clean as we thought that was a civil war
over there that we got involved in
unfortunately
um
for who knows what reason and uh it was
a mistake for us to do that and uh
i was there i know it was a mistake from
what i saw i saw
absolute poverty they said they told us
about the domino effect they told us
that these people were going to come
over and take us over and i thought my
god we're going to have a hell of a long
vote
all right sir thank you a lot for the
call when you went back were you
surprised at what the country looked
like
yes
in 1990
november 1990 that's the first time i've
been back there after 16 years it really
um
um surprised me to see the level of
poverty hunger was it worse uh it's
worse yeah it's to me it's rolled back
20 30 years compared to 1975.
most everybody will have for work
no public service
people on the
even as we speak in saigon ho chi minh
city now
every other day there's no electric city
it's
getting getting better with not much let
me grab this car from king county
washington go ahead please hello brian
and then hello to the rest of your
guests
my father was killed in vietnam uh
august 29 1964.
that's early
pardon that was early that was real
early and we've kind of grown up with
that i almost feel like a veteran
growing up with the darn war but i'm not
what service was he in air force pilot
and he killed it ben was a matter of
fact right outside of saigon coming in
for a landing on his own air base
what i wanted to say
is that two things one about the
prosthetics i think it's a fantastic
program the university of washington is
doing a lot of stuff over there i don't
know how much aid is actually getting to
vietnam
in america i used to run a tour rental
store we could buy wheelchairs that
would come in the door used for twenty
bucks we could sell those same
wheelchairs in three days for four
hundred dollars
the cheapest two-wheel
wheelchair is about five hundred fifty
dollars to a person who doesn't have
money to buy them you go into a
motorized wheelchair you can spend six
seven eight thousand dollars
yet as a contractor in america we spend
millions of dollars redoing curbs for
access to the handicapped and yet how
many handicapped people can really get
around
the next thing as far as normalization
of relations i'm all for it i think the
sooner the country is going to heal and
put vietnam and back of us we're going
to have to normalize relations and part
of that is we have a very large
vietnamese population who are americans
now how many vietnamese do you know of
around seattle
oh maybe 20
a lot of them work at the hospitals but
there are a lot more that live there oh
there's thousands of them up here okay
thanks a lot for your call now seattle
is where the doctor is from that dr
ernie burgess and the prostate research
center there and they're the ones who
established that
uh prosthetic center there in hanoi let
me go back to the first caller when he
talked about the humanitarian efforts
that are being made means in his mind
that this thing's over
that was one of the reasons i remember
you telling us a long time ago that you
got involved in this whole mia pow thing
with the vessi commission in the first
place that's right because that's what
really began to speed up the powmi
process was the
realization or the determination by
america at that time to separate out the
humanitarian issues from the political
and economic issues that separated the
two countries and that's the reason
humanitarian thing has been able to grow
there are approximately and uh this
number is close among almost a hundred
separate groups that are now registered
to work in vietnam humanitarian groups
on the contributions to your your
vietnamese uh
handicap
give me the whole title of it's a
vietnam assistance for the handicap yes
your organization what kind of money do
you need from individuals that will help
you
well as little as 50 dollars
contribution we can provide a limbs
artificial limb to the amputee in
vietnam
and the
dog
the donor would then receive a
photograph in the receipt
of the
amputee that we actually delivered just
like i said a little while ago
my september trip to vietnam i will be
there for a couple weeks
filling the limbs that we
order
we we go directly to the individual and
with video and camera and photograph to
for accountability because
as you mentioned earlier
i'm working in an environment that i
need to be
constantly prove that i'm in the middle
are we not there to support the system
or endorse the government of vietnam in
any way or shelf or form we're there for
one thing and one thing only to extend
it some assistance to the needy
the war victim
the former ovens amputee as well as
civilians and we want to do it for for
once this is the organization that not
mingling into the political system
even if the communist system gonna stay
there
one week one year or ten year down the
road
whoever else going in there should you
know
still needed help gallatin tennessee
you're next
uh yes this is frank from gallatin
tennessee and uh
i was in vietnam with the first cab and
uh
and the 101st airborne uh 65-56 with the
first cab 68-59 with the screaming
eagles
and uh to me the war has been over for a
long time i uh
i go to
uh i've been going to the vva counselors
down and i'm down in nashville tennessee
just a little ways from where i live and
the war is over uh the only only war
i've got left is with jane fonda and
jane was so proud of the north why isn't
she sending money she's married in the
tbs now and uh got all kinds of money i
get a little emotional on this subject
but uh
why isn't she sending money if north
vietnam was so good and i'm uh my father
was born in a communist country and
uh well not a communist but
a dictatorship government and uh where's
that uh cuba
uh and uh i've got family still in cuba
and i thought like i said my brother uh
like i said i was in vietnam my older
brother
fought in korea with the 82nd
and uh
i have no problem with vietnam i think
that and matter of fact i wrote down mr
carr's number if i'm pronouncing the
name right i'm gonna send some money
uh i've got no problem with the with the
vietnamese people they were soldiers the
nba
vc were soldiers just like i was
i'm proud to be an american and i'm
proud that i went and fought not some
some guys don't feel that way and that's
their privilege
uh but the vietnamese people uh i'd like
to say the first time i was stationed in
on k
uh and then i was up
i was in way with the hunt first and
then uh
caisson and all around and uh
i think that that's a good thing i think
the vietnamese people need help all
right gallatin thanks for the call is
the war over for you yet oh yes war is
done
where's done and it helped writing those
three books
well each one of them came at a certain
stage i didn't know the next one was
coming you know uh
it's important to point out here
something that i i discovered myself
about midway through the since i've been
working this since 87 and i discovered
in about 80 or 89 i guess
and that is
south vietnam which i hated almost as
much as north vietnam by the time i got
out i just hated all vietnamese
uh which was a signal of the depth of
you know what i've gone through and
really reflects on your own self-hatred
at times like that
thinking it was the right thing to do
well i realized that um
wait a minute you know
and when i made those realizations that
the vietnamese we fought for the ones we
fought against were human beings why it
began to change in my mind
and i realized for the first time that
you know half of that country of vietnam
were our allies and those people there
still were there
after we left and so what we're doing
now is really laying the groundwork
to allow call and cause going down and
and putting putting forth the effort
that really is the people-to-people
effort that makes this whole thing work
when you came to this country in 1975 or
76 75 how long did you work as a janitor
before you moved up to being a chef
uh last about two and a half months
how long were you a chef uh a cook for
the restaurant for
less than a week i think about a week
when did you what year did you have your
first taco amigo
in 1981
and now you have four
i had five but i had to sell one because
it's um
it's a lot of work a lot of work so we
we're gonna cut it back
lakeland florida go ahead please
brian this is a jim robbins
i'm a vietnam veteran hi jim robbins uh
i served with the
173rd and the first cav
and the 5 18 mps down in saigon in 65 66
67
70 and 71. wow how come so long i
thought i had a job to do and i kept
going back over in fact uh
i made my first trip back to vietnam in
may of 89 and i made six trips since
then to vietnam why
uh it's really emotional i got involved
with the pown i issue
after my third trip back to vietnam and
made a lot of headway and i reported my
information to the state department and
treasury apartments
i made four trips to washington to
discuss the things that
were passed on to me and because of it
our government has uh forced me into
bankruptcy
they had threatened to take my passport
away from me and they've given me a real
hard time
for the last two years
from from your perspective why have they
done this
uh because they don't want the truth to
come out and uh
i faxed senator curry a fax last week
his office did call me but i got the
same impression from them brian
that uh they don't want to know
and uh it's really been real hard on me
because uh
on each of my trips over to vietnam i
had my house broken too three times
my businesses were broken to twice
and uh
one time i was taking off the air
airplane and stripped in the airport all
right sir thanks for the call sounds
like the gentleman's had a tough time
that's right and um some people
sometimes make times tough for
themselves that it's a difficult
situation to be in san pablo california
hello how you doing fine sir what's on
your mind my name is rodney burton and i
served in the united states army
and i was in the communications branch
and uh
during the times when uh bulk rights and
several other people were involved with
the
military finding out if pow mias were
there
i have information that there was a
cover-up
okay as far as sightings and
you know just basic facts but i can't
prove it because that's classified
material all right sir thank you um
what do you think of bogreitz
do you know him oh i don't know him no i
follow him at all uh well you can't help
but follow him he's in the news a lot do
you know why
well he's uh recently it's been because
of uh he used to be in special forces i
believe he very active in the plwmia
issue and
i don't think i'll make any comments
because i really don't have any any
information that i know is valid or not
everything i have is second and third
hand on individuals such as himself and
others i think a lot of uh
i think one reason the uh carry
commission or the kerry uh committee is
going to be important is it's going to
bring out a lot of facts that maybe uh
you know people don't believe the
government anymore there's always a
conspiracy theory and there will always
be a certain percentage of people who
will never believe
the results whatever they are
i think what we really have to do is
look at the honest efforts been put in
by a lot of people over the years where
we are today
and we got to put our lives in balance
and
that's not saying we abandoned and
forget
it says we have to make decisions about
based on the facts we have and and and
how much can we go over the plowed
ground and have we looked at all the
issues and all the facts out and once
all that stuff is out whenever that
decision is made it's all out
then i think people with
you know who look at it in an objective
way will have to say okay we've done
what we can do do you feel
that you've been accepted by the
american people
do you mean here in this community yes
sir oh yeah yeah the very first moment i
got here
uh
everything all ready to go
the infrastructure and everything else
you know so we
it lost no time at all to to blend in
i had no problem at all did you speak
english i speak english yeah then no at
the time yeah southport north carolina
go ahead please hi my name is joanne
brown
um
there were certain questions that i had
about this program that's going on i
feel
like um
people in america have had so many
problems in the war the men that have
gone to the war in the war are now
here are they not getting any help they
are the ones that need the help the ones
that are over here that have been in the
war see i have no prejudice to either
side because my father was american or
is american my mother's vietnamese so
i'm amerasian
and so i'm not prejudiced to both sides
but why is it that mr khan wants to ask
america to help them america has done so
much for the vietnamese that not very
many people know about
both of you
go ahead first well
i have to say that's that's that's
that's the american spirit i mean we're
made up of uh nationalities from all
over the world and
we help other people uh
and so uh
kyle's vietnamese american i suppose if
you look at mom irish uh french
welsh american if you want to look back
that far it's what it is what we are
today and once you achieve certain
things in your life
you
you have to say now i need to do things
for other people
and
vietnam for me personally
affected my life an affected cause and
that's something that we have a joint
concern and we can be united in doing
something good there
well the to me this is a
humanitarian program
uh we go across
and above the
ratio of the
restrictions if you will
i don't think this is two vietnamese or
americans we we reach out to everybody
unfortunate unfortunately the lady has
that
thought but
to me and to our program this a total
humanitarian we need to reach out for
these people
i think the americans uh publish for for
for certain stance to kind of take it
for granted
that we got it made i'm an american now
and i know
um
compared to the suffering that the
people that left behind vietnam uh
america abandoned the south vietnamese
ones
and in in this process of normalizing
and what's not going on uh i think a
humanitarian program has to be uh
aggressive uh pursued should the embargo
be lifted in your opinion
uh
i i will not uh
get into that area
um
it's beyond what we're trying to do here
you know new york city go ahead please
hi it's john mcauliffe
i'm the head of an organization called
the u.s indochina reconciliation project
and i'm calling
on behalf of a whole mix of
organizations that are called the us ngo
forum on vietnam cambodia and laos
both fred and tron are people that i
know and admire the the work they're
doing
i wanted to
say that that your shows what you've
been doing all spring and what senator
kerry has been doing
his committee have been doing have
really been
trying to lance the boil in a way trying
to bring
present realities to bear against
memories
that have too long crippled
american policy and american relations
with vietnam what is your usno china
project do we sponsor academic exchanges
we've sponsored some visits by
foundation people we've brought a number
of students to study in the united
states from vietnam and cambodia
we've organized a conference for
overseas khmer with
ministry people in phnom penh to talk
about development problems sent english
teachers to cambodia uh
we've existed for about six or seven
years and what's your own background
were you a veteran
a veteran of the anti-war movement uh
it's the other part of the history i
started out in the peace corps and the
civil rights movement in mississippi
and when i got back from the peace corps
it was 1966 and
i became involved as a conscientious
objector in anti-war activity and then
worked for the quakers for 10 years the
friends service committee how do you
find yourself
looked upon by people who were veterans
now
generally very positively i mean one of
the big uh
misnomers or big phony stories i think
is that
there's a conflict between veterans and
and you people who are in the anti-war
movement
uh for one thing many veterans were
themselves including senator kerry
active in the anti-war movement
uh for another if you look at the polls
that were taken in the first few years
after the end of the war
were actually people who opposed the war
were much more sympathetic to special
programs for veterans whether it was
agent orange or training programs or
post-traumatic stress disorder programs
then were the average american or the
american who supported the war so
many of the people who have now
organized groups to help vietnam are
veterans fred's one of them but but
there are dozens of others uh
tron is is one of the first of the
vietnamese american community that's
stuck his neck out
and tried to provide aid but i think
he's just the opening of a big wave
that's coming all right john mccullough
thanks a lot for calling
yeah john's uh
john's been very very active and
certainly became i never heard of any of
these people before 1987 and then i uh
all of a sudden was introduced to a
whole range of individuals such as
himself who had
had a lot of different ideas that i had
to
accept and or adjust and accept to and
think about and
even though we may have different
opinions and maybe different
philosophies and ideas our end goal is
the same and i think that mutual respect
comes out if we're trying to get
something done
next call cape cod massachusetts go
ahead please yeah brian
i served in the marine corps in vietnam
in 1967 and 1968 through the tet
offensive and i went back 20 years later
in the early part of 1988
to see if i could affect some kind of
change in our attitude towards vietnam
and maybe find out some of the answers
to the haunting questions that vietnam
vets had
and it was a real eye-opener for me it
was a very traumatic experience for me
and i'm sure that has been for a lot of
other men that have gone since that time
but at that time only 1900 approximately
americans had been back into vietnam and
most of them were government officials
or journalists
and
we felt like we were way out on a limb
and
uh it wasn't just an extraordinary
experience one of the the things that i
learned that really uh was an eye-opener
that was that
one of the largest oil refineries in the
entire far east was being built in
bangtao
and the united states had punched a
bunch of wells in the um
sea off the coast of ang tao was pumping
oil
uh the soviet union had taken over those
wells after the war was pumping oil into
it and i had heard at that time by 1992
that it was going to be one of the
largest operational oil refineries in
the world
but um there was a lot of other things
that were real eye openers and as i've
watched your program it has been a
crushing experience for me
especially thinking about people that
have been left behind and
i'm very grateful for some of the people
that have called and have voiced an
opinion on that and i'd like to thank
you for allowing me to do the same all
right cape cod massachusetts thanks you
know this article that was in the august
23rd issue of parade magazine written by
jim webb who will be with us on
thursday uh by the way thursday is going
to be devoted mostly to the economics of
that part of the world jim clad
will be here also who is with the
carnegie endowment and he is a new
zealand citizen uh has spent a lot of
time in the united states and he talks
about
his experience living over in that part
of the world i want to go back to this
article i just want to read you a little
bit here it says this is jim webb
writing former secretary of the navy i
am becoming angry at the arrogance of my
inspectors this is when you arrive in in
saigon i slam a suitcase onto the table
dry or maybe this is annoying drawing
threatening stairs and then i learn a
valuable lesson from my friend kavan
tran who has endured each indignity
before
kai is screaming at them too they are
warning him that he is on the edge of
arrest they confiscate four tape
videotapes that already had been
screened for political content last
summer in ho chi minh city they pulled
him from his hotel and detained him for
four days of questioning never giving
him a reason and it goes on and on about
your experience there were they have
they been treating you difficult in a
difficult way on your return um
it was somewhat expected on my part to
uh going through these difficulties
both here and back home in vietnam
but what happened with jim
the experience with jim at the airport
is somewhat a little bit a little bit
too much for us to
for me to react at the moment
the breakdown of the
internal communication between hanoi and
the
authority at the airport obviously
evidence
before i left hanoi
i was instructed by the interior
ministry that any problem you know
there's a hotline for me to contact them
uh when that going on i
blatantly forgot about that hot
telephone number you know uh but anyway
it's it's uh it's to me i take it to a
lesser stand for the the problem that
that's happened um
no communication
from the central to the
local level um
the guy down the local level is king for
the moment by the time you get the uh
the world up onto into hanoi you know
probably a days or so past so you have
to try to get you know uh basically you
can however i have to add here that
after the incident
the mid-level officer from hanoi
traveled here to attended the
conference and your conference they came
to
my organization to apologize
from his government as well as
to mr
jim webb
so you know it's kind of
misunderstanding
and the incident that we very much
expected in you know for for the time
being
grant county washington you're next
hi um i called mostly today to talk to
fred downs this is lynn nichols fred out
washington state
how are you fine how you doing good good
listen the main reason i call today i
want to i want to compliment fred
he's an american that uh and a
government official that we can all be
proud of
he's done a hell of a job of of working
on behalf of the veterans in this
country
uh particularly amputees
and at the same time uh gotten out there
and
danced around a real sensitive issue of
reconciliation with vietnam and i just
i've uh it's been a pleasure to get to
know fred and i just want to compliment
it are you by chance a
a veteran yes i am an amputee yes what
uh
when was your
injury what year
1967. and what was it
uh gunshot wound
and how you doing now oh i'm doing real
well real well
thank you thank you thank you
thanks for calling
you know yeah
he's a helicopter pilot
and um
and or at least i think he's a
helicopter pilot yes he was part of the
group that
got that
research center going in hanoi as a
matter of fact
and he's the one who worked with ernie
burgess at the beginning and and uh
got quite involved i personally didn't
think all that new technology would work
there but they they had the fire and the
spirit they went ahead and did it anyway
so they proved i was wrong luckily i
want to reckon we're going to take a
call from hanoi now they're not watching
it i know we have somebody that we want
to talk to there and i want to recommend
that we call the jacksonville florida
caller back when we're ready because
he's on the line they're paying money
and that's not fair and i'll punch it up
here bob dalton are you there
hello
hello bob dalton can you hear us
yes i can hear you well we've got uh
we're gonna have your picture on the
screen here for those of uh our viewers
back here who don't remember your
participation the last time we did this
what are you doing in vietnam and in
hanoi if we might ask
well i came over here
to make arrangements for the seminars as
you recall
i told you we were participating in a
program to
do uh seminars on the effects of a free
market economy on a socialist system
here in vietnam
and that's what i've been here for
making the prior arrangements
what time of day is it
there it's about 4 30. why are you
upstairs why are you up so early
someone made a telephone call
and what have you found how long have
you been there
oh i've been here um oh about uh a week
and a half now
and what are you finding on this trip
well each trip is uh is unique as i
mentioned uh last time and uh this time
just a continuation of whatever i've
observed before about the increased
economic activity
all the various nations
that are in here
working and doing business in the
country seems to be moving along rather
well
on its economic development a lot of
building going on
any new companies any new countries that
you've uh discovered that are are more
involved now than they were say four or
five months ago when we were there
well i i think the japanese are much
more involved um um with with hard
dollars at the moment
um yesterday i went out to a building
that uh they had just built a brand new
modern building uh called a um a
friendship house
it's a building for japanese businessmen
to use
while they're in town doing business
modern modern glass building
now now when is your conference going to
be held
we'll be holding a seminar at the end of
the month
in
the economic university at ho chi minh
city
on the 28th of september
there'll be three professors coming over
here
for the purposes of teaching
uh various various modern modern uh
business subjects and who will attend
your conference
there will be two groups of thirty in
viva the majority of them will be
master's degree students
students
studying for a master's degree and in
some cases
[Music]
mid-level
[Music]
bureaucrats that need to know how to do
business uh with people in the united
states
we have two people here at our table
that you probably know kav and tran who
has the project as you know on uh for
the handicap down in uh
down in the southern part of the state i
guess do you do you go to the whole
country or just the south yes we just
started on the mekong delta area for now
yeah and fred downs is here who i'm sure
you know and i think fred might have a
question for you yeah bob how you doing
brian fred good to hear you good good to
see all that work you're doing there my
question is each time i return to
vietnam there's always something new and
growing and it's major change in the
country
what is it this time that you've noticed
in vietnam
well um oh i don't know it it happens to
be a holiday now
yesterday was
a founder's day sort of like our fourth
of july
um
no this time but quite busy you know
with the bureaucracy as you know trying
to get to get things done
i just say
new
and new economic growth each time new
new faces new people involved
some old faces that you and i have seen
for for years but
many many new faces you come in contact
at all with the m-i-a-p-o-w issue
no no
for that for that issue i i've sort of
let our government handle that over the
years that's that's something that the
government i think is doing a fairly
decent job with and what about projects
like uh cavantran are you aware of his
project with the handicapped and do you
get any impact do you get any feedback
when you're over there
of course
each time you come here you you hear
about other people uh and kai and i and
old friends in fact cars started his
project basically after
we started our our project up in hanoi
and
we met and
hopefully we've been able to help them
where we could
bob dalton anything else you want to add
we'll let you go back to sleep
no no no other than the
thank you for calling and uh uh is is
your show now the the the a new and
updated show of uh what transpired in
the past well what we're doing is
showing of the videotape that you saw
when you were here before and then
updating it with live interviews and
call-in shows
ah now one thing i'd like to mention i
did run into fred asked for something
new and unique
um i'd like to mention that i ran into a
fellow here from an american from new
york who was running a marathon in
january he ran one last year
over 60 americans came and ran
in the south and here this year they're
running in the north i thought it was
quite unique that he's gathering people
from all around the world uh to to
participate in a sports event here in
this country and
and i thought it was sort of a good way
for people to communicate when are they
going to have this marathon and is he
putting the whole thing together himself
well he
he's got a number of sponsors um
of course he can have no american
sponsors he's got
he's um works out of hong kong i think
and
my responses like lufthansa
and um various other other foreign
sponsors that participated in it and
he's got one section of the marathon
didn't do having to do with um
handicapped people
and
a lot of u.s american handicapped
veterans participate i i thought that
was quite unique again bob thanks very
much for joining us
okay my pleasure and and good luck to
you all have a nice trip
bye-bye that bring back memories of your
trips to hanoi oh yeah
waking up at 4 30 in the morning whether
it's a phone call or not it's usually
because a truck was backfiring
jacksonville florida go ahead please
okay am i on yes and thank you did you
wait all this time uh no uh y'all call
me back as a matter of fact okay thank
you okay
what's on your mind today
uh well i already explained that once no
you gotta explain it to me because we're
on the air now oh okay we're you're live
you're on television go ahead and tell
us what uh what you're thinking about
oh i'm live now yes sir oh okay cool
uh yeah my name is uh michael well how
come they're talking still it's because
your television set's turned up you need
to turn the volume down because you're
getting the feedback tell me when to
talk yeah just go ahead as soon as she
turns the volume down or here hey
this is michael gas from jacksonville
florida am i getting through to you you
bet
all right
uh
i've been watching your show all day and
i really appreciate the attention and
obviously the feedback that you're
getting from us vietnam veterans
um
i don't know you're supposed to ask me
questions or what
well
basically most people that call have
either a question to ask of our guests
or i got to say something about their
irvine character okay uh his uh accuracy
and media uh
kind of uh reminds me of a word
combination military intelligence
doesn't exist his uh
information is completely incorrect and
i appreciate you doing this story to
bring some attention to us but uh my
problem
or you know what i think uh i'd like to
see you do a story on us vietnam
veterans
you know that we haven't been addressed
fifty thousand plus uh
thousand on the wall
one third of all the nations homeless or
vietnam veterans
uh you know we still got people that
aren't accounted for
300 000 wounded
we're talking 80 000 suicides
and uh you know we didn't have any help
for a long time
all right sir thanks a lot for joining
us today
well i'm part of the department of
veterans affairs and our
our budget next year is going to be
about 34 billion dollars and uh
so we're spending a lot of that money uh
someplace out there on veterans we have
uh
tremendo any neglect during the 70s or
60s has certainly been corrected in the
latter part of the 80s certainly during
the 80s with all the the attention and
the turnaround and now we're beginning
to enter the decade of the 90s and i can
assure you that no stone is being left
unturned and the real proof of that
brian is what happened after desert
storm there are complaints now about the
oil well fires causing problems well
there's no resistance now to let's find
out if that's true or not and we're
developing registers the va is right in
the middle of that so i think something
that did happen good from vietnam and
vets coming back and being ignored is we
don't ignore him anymore how we're
getting into how much of that 34 billion
dollars will go to vietnam connected
either disabilities or
i would benefit i wouldn't have that
information off the top of my head uh
you know it's all i'd have to sit down
and go through the numbers which we have
but you have uh the department of
veterans affairs
which is broken into three parts part is
the veterans benefits
second is the hospitalization and the
third is the cemetery service which
i'm not anxious to get into that section
yet
trump
your project again for those who have
tuned in late
is called the vietnam assistance for the
handicap yes
you've been back to vietnam four times
you first went back what 1989
1990 1990
you've been an american citizen for how
long
uh
1984.
and if somebody wants to contribute some
money and you say fifty dollars would be
the minimum contribution
far then no minimum i don't set the
minimum but if it's uh fifty dollars
uh
we can provide a limb to the amputee in
the
clinic that we we operated at in canter
in kanto you have a clinic that you
personally operate do you pay for the
whole clinic no this the being operated
by the
vietnam vietnamese it is a former clinic
that operated by
the republic of vietnam before during
the war
and after that the government took over
and keep it at the same operation
we use that
clinic to facilitate the operation that
we support
encounter
how do you and the numbers on the screen
how do you
protect people who say if i send you
money how do i know it's going to go to
what you say it's going to go to well we
are a
non-profit organization we set up and
have license with tax exempt
501c3 from the iis we have the
treasury's department and commerce
license to work in vietnam
we go beyond that
in terms of accountability for the
donors whoever give us money we have no
overhead cost we have no office no
secretary to fund for everything going
through us and go directly to the
amputee so you don't take any money for
yourself no we
are doing this for nothing greensboro
north carolina go ahead please
yes i'm calling i've been watching your
show for the past couple days and i
really appreciate this i was with the
ninth marines over
vietnam
67-68 up on the caisson in that area
and my first question is
you know there's been several callers
that called in here today or the same
situation like myself
who you know are handicapped and also on
disability and we have very little money
to live on
i'm talking about less than a thousand
dollars are you on total disability
no so i get 40 percent and in va and
they hassled me for about three or four
years trying to get that
and then and then the second thing i
wanted to bring up and i don't think it
was during the parole hearings and you
mentioned when he brought up about that
raid that they did on a song pay you
know to get the powmis out
the prison up north near hanoi
correct
what a lot of people don't know you know
the reason why that place was empty when
they went in there because jane fonda
was coming over there for a visit so
they took all those prisoners out there
yeah and i still have a lot of hatred
for those people and everything but i
think it's a great show and everything
but the va the hassle that they give you
and trying to get especially and i you
know i've got multiple sclerosis
i'm going blind
and then you know and then
and then the thoughts you have every day
all right sir thanks uh for your call
well you know we have a
when you have a combat injured veteran
uh it's a relatively a very very
open and shut kind of thing lost the
land then it's so much percentage
disability and that's pretty clear when
you get into other areas such as the
disease he just mentioned it's a
progressive type of disease it
complicates your life when did it occur
did it occur in service and it becomes
very very complicated and
and uh
we have a bureaucracy that one must go
through in order to apply for these
benefits and so
these guys do have a tough way to go
sometimes but we have
we have people there to deal with it and
if they don't like the way we do it the
veteran service organizations have
service officers and this is an
important point all of this because
there are people out there who who
really feel they deserve more and we
have a system and we work within that
system and they must too
last call everett washington go ahead
please
uh yes my name is daryl ritchie and uh
i just know fred very well i just like
america to know
that we appreciate what he's doing on
behalf of the vietnam veterans
and
how do you know fred downs mr ritchie uh
we come from the same area and uh went
to school together where'd you go from
you from indiana uh from illinois
oh terre haute indiana right right
across from terrell indiana daryl it's
good to hear from you
this is great send me your address
just send it to you send it to me there
at the veterans administration just got
a letter from your wife oh and uh i
really want just wanting on behalf the
people that lost someone over in vietnam
that we're really proud of what you're
doing to make this a better
a better country and better
relationships between vietnam and
america and we just want to thank you
and give your appreciation thanks mr
richard for calling i thought we lost
his address i'm glad we still have it
yeah it's good how's your book on on
growing up in indiana coming
i'm struggling with it every night on
weekends not every night like i should
and
it'll be an intro i'll have to have you
proofread it since you're from indiana
also
i'm not so sure that i can help you uh
back to you this is a small question but
not to do with your vietnam assistance
for the handicap but what's been the
toughest thing for you and in owning
restaurants in this country a mexican
restaurant for mexican restaurants
well the toughest part of the um
being an owner and operator at the same
time
as you know
not too many americans
uh owe and operate restaurant anymore
they have been seen to get out it's
because so tough you know it's only big
company
pepsi callers
baseball owner all this now and they
don't have to work
that's the toughest part you know own it
and work it open the clothes every day
it's tremendous pretty demanding
taco amigos the name of those
restaurants yes
a vietnamese american owning four
mexican american mexican restaurants are
they are they sit down restaurants are
they fast food yeah family style
family stuff and your next trip back is
two weeks from now
two weeks from now this is going to be a
very very significant trip
so so far
whereas we have over 300 amputees
he's waiting at the clinic for me
to be given the artificial limbs and
is to make about another 300 to be
registered for a
subsequent trip
so one last time on the screen we need
the telephone number in case somebody
wants to contribute to
mr cavantrans
let's see if we can get that number up
on the screen they're probably not ready
to do it while they're finding it i want
to ask fred downs you're going to go
back to vietnam soon
i don't know soon we are probably
scheduled to go back next spring to
review all the work that's being done
and to look at areas like cause to see
where and what if we can help
uh you know you'd ask earlier what we've
been doing for the us government i
neglected to mention that part of our
usaid money this year in addition what i
already said is 1.5 million will be
given for assistance for displaced
children and orphans and that's an
important number
fred downs the veterans administration
and author of uh no longer enemies not
yet friends and two other books and
kavantran who is the gentleman who
started the vietnam assistance for the
handicapped based in northern virginia
and the telephone number was on the
screen thank you both for joining us
thank you thank you
vietnam revisited has two more days to
go we want to show you the schedule
for the next couple of days
and tomorrow james clad carnegie
endowment for an hour we'll talk about
the economics of that part of the world
u.s vietnam relations is also on the
schedule former navy secretary james
webb will be here who also went on a
trip to vietnam back in may with
cavantran and phones of course will be
open
all the day that videotape you're
looking at by the way is in hanoi and
it's we're walking back
to see where some of the wreckage from
the b-52 is still sitting there right in
the middle of this little village on
friday senate p-o-w mia affairs
committee
arrival
in hanoi trip to the army museum
that they took the hanoi prison tour
that was uh
spontaneous back in april uh by that
committee and then about two and a half
hours of video down in the mekong delta
where john kerry and senator bob smith
both go back to places that americans
haven't been
uh
in a long time fuqua the southernmost
base there in
mekong delta where john kerry was
stationed during the vietnam war and
also kanto and other stops and that
looks like the schedule for the final
two days
of
vietnam revisited thank you for joining
us today
and have a good evening
[Music]
grab it down
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
up
uh
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
thank you
so
english language news from countries
around the globe and the bb